Ja.
Hallo.
Da sind wir wieder.
Wir zwei.
Wir zwei ohne Nummer drei. Nummer drei ist...
Wo bin ich denn heute? Bin ich immer noch rechts?
Äh links?
Du bist links.
Okay.
Ja und ich bin rechts. So wie gehabt. Nee, ich war sonst in der Mitte. Weil rechts ist frei, weil Olle Max ganz kurzfristig beschlossen hat, in den Urlaub zu fahren. Auf dem Malle.
Genau.
Der twittert da drüber, das kann man sagen. Echt? Ja, ich hab das auch nur aus Twitter. Ist ja nicht so, dass er mir irgendwas sagen will.
Ich fahr mal dahin, damit ich in Twitter berichten kann, wo ich bin.
Ja, der ist total drauf. Der kann gar nicht ohne. Der liegt da am Strand.
Nee, der ist nur deswegen da.
Was? Wegen Twitter? Wieso?
Na, weil es cooler ist als Twitter-Meldung, weil man mal woanders ist.
Na, das kann er auch schreiben, ohne dahin zu fahren. Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es mal jetzt so cool ist.
Ich glaube, die machen sowas.
Ja, da müssen wir auf jeden Fall mal hinterfragen, wie es war. Ich hoffe, dass er uns auch alle schmutzigen Details dieses Abenteuerurlaubs dann mitteilen wird. Und wir wollen natürlich die Sachen, die noch nicht über Twitter gelaufen sind. Nicht wahr? Ja, mit anderen Worten. Erst mal Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Mobile Max, Podcast Nummer 6.
Post WWDC.
Genau, das Aftermath sozusagen. Und wir haben uns extra nochmal um zwei Tage verschoben, sonst treffen wir uns ja immer am Montag. Hier ist noch nichts richtig eingespielt. Ich halte den Mittwoch eigentlich für gar keine schlechte Idee, weil das kommt doch sowieso immer alles an.
Hatten wir da früher eben Montags? Du hast ja auf Montag verschoben und jetzt ist wieder Mittwoch.
Ich bin schuld?
Aber wir hatten immer Mittwochs vorher.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist Max nicht da. Max ist im Urlaub und hat uns überlassen, die Analyse vorzunehmen. Das werden wir dann auch mal tun heute. Ich hatte ja gestern schon nochmal was ins Blog geschrieben. Das hatte ich jetzt gerade ganz vergessen noch zu recherchieren. Da sind ja so diverse Fragen auch gekommen, was wir denn mal so noch behandeln sollen. Da kann ich gleich sagen, bei den manchen müssen wir dann auch ein wenig in die Glaskugel schauen, weil zwar ist jetzt die Keynote gelaufen, aber alles andere, was dort verkündet wird, liegt natürlich unter einem NDA, wie das so schön ist.
Ja, aber es wird natürlich trotzdem durchsickern.
Es wird natürlich durchsickern, nur ist jetzt nach zwei Tagen, die sitzen ja noch alle ganz brav und machen Männchen und lauschen den Auguren, um irgendwie zu schauen. Wie viele Leute sind auf dieser Veranstaltung?
5.000. Ausverkauft auf jeden Fall zum ersten Mal.
Sind es 5.000 irgendwas oder sind es 50.000 irgendwas?
Nein, 50.000, das wäre ein Stadionfall, das geht gar nicht.
Ja, bei irgendeinem...
Da hat ja einer was geschrieben.
Ich war vorhin so ein bisschen im Diderium und habe noch irgendwie bei Bits und so reingehört und er hat irgendwas mit 50.000 gesagt. Ich glaube, das stimmt nicht. Na wie auch immer, kommen wir mal lieber zu den Fakten. Also erstmal wollte ich noch ein paar Sachen nachholen, die ich nämlich letztes Mal vergessen habe zu erwähnen. Und zwar habe ich jetzt hier auf dem Tisch die CT-Spezial-Mac.
Die ja nachgedruckt wurde, weil der Ansturm so riesengroß war.
Genau, da dürften Sie sich gewundert haben. Und ich muss sagen, das ist eigentlich ein ganz akkurates Heft. Also das kann man so einem Umsteiger, also hier steht ja Einsteiger, Umsteiger, Aufsteiger. Umsteiger ist rot, warum auch immer. Aber ich glaube, für Umsteiger ist es eigentlich auch gedacht, weil die extrem viel auch so aus dieser vergleichenden Perspektive, so nach dem Motto auf dem Macintosh, ist das so und so.
Und dieses und jenes.
Also damit die Leute mit ihren Windows-Metaphern irgendwie dann...
Genau, und das ist eigentlich ganz cool gemacht. Erstmal stellen sie sozusagen generell vor, wie das so mit dieser Produktpalette eigentlich aussieht, also wie sich das alles so macht. Also die ganzen Macs werden vorgestellt und dann haben sie noch einen Artikel über jeden Einzelnen, also über den iMac, Mac Mini und so weiter, Mac Pro und die Mac Books und Mac Book Pro, so und das R. Und damit füllt sie sozusagen hier schon mal den ersten Teil. Ganz gute Geschichte, um sozusagen einen Einblick zu kriegen, was es überhaupt gibt. Und dann gehen sie auf Mac OS X ein und auch dort erstmal fangen sie mit so einem Überblick an und dann sieht man halt schon, jetzt geht es gleich irgendwie, das nächste Teil ist dann so Windows installieren, Virtualisierungssoftware und so weiter, das ist also ganz klar eigentlich auf Umsteiger gemünzt und dann halt auch so Tipps zum Upgrade und dann geht es auf die Software und dann werden die ganzen iLife, iWork wird alles vorgestellt, natürlich auch Office, ganz klar, aber dann auch so, wie macht man so Videoschnitt, Final Cut Express, so aber auch so Logic Studio, auch ein paar Pro Apps, Lightroom, Aperture, also das wird alles vorgestellt. Dann kommen halt so, naja, dann gibt es noch diese DVD dabei, wo Software drauf ist, die Auswahl ist so, naja, ganz okay, so ein bisschen das, was man so erwarten würde. Was aber wirklich cool ist, die haben da, was sagen sie, acht Stunden, also richtig viel Screencasts gemacht, also die erklären so richtig in Screencasts, im Flash-Format, so Schritt für Schritt, so geht das, und hier ist irgendwie das Apfelmenü und tralala, wenn du da draufklickst und auch so mit so ein paar ganz brauchbaren Tipps, also jetzt wirklich nicht nur für Dove, sondern es ist schon ganz gut gemacht, auch von der Qualität her sehr gut gemacht und kann ich eigentlich nur zum nicken. Also ist jetzt für einen erfahrenen Macintosh-Benutzer ist nicht so viel dabei, aber so für den Umsteiger ist es wirklich super. Hier auch das Media Center und Apple TV findet auch nochmal Erwähnung und die iPods und das iPhone natürlich. Also es ist gar nicht so sehr ein Mac-Spezial, es ist eigentlich mehr so ein Apple-Spezial. Also das ist dann hier auch Coexistenz mit Windows, im Netzwerk und hier Parental-Controls.
Mac-Spezial kommen wir gleich zum nächsten Thema schon, weil Mac gibt es irgendwie nicht mehr.
Wie? Mac gibt es nicht mehr?
Es heißt jetzt nicht mehr Mac OS X, es heißt jetzt nur noch OS X Leopard, gerade zumindest.
Ja, aber da scheint sich Apple auch noch nicht ganz so einig zu sein, wenn man da auf die Webseiten schaut, also auch der Ausblick auf das nächste OS X, den Schnee-Leo, da steht auch noch Mac OS. Also mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar, was sie da für eine Strategie fahren. Irgendwie wollen sie schon darauf hin, dass allen Leuten klar wird. Und ich glaube, es geht vor allem um die Developer dabei. Weil dadurch, dass sie jetzt das iPhone, also ich meine die World Wide Developer's Conference ist deshalb so voll, weil einfach alle Firmen ihre Hacker dahin geschickt haben, und gesagt haben, du musst jetzt lernen, wie man fürs iPhone programmiert, weil wir brauchen jetzt mal ganz schnell ab.
Das glaube ich gar nicht so.
Aber hallo, ich glaube die Hälfte der Leute, die da sind, sind einfach nur wegen des iPhones da. Und das Coole ist natürlich, dass der Synergieeffekt da ist. Alle Leute, die jetzt iPhone lernen, lernen quasi automatisch Macintosh-Programmierung from the ground up. Eben mit der Unterschied, dass das Cocoa-Uhr eigentlich dabei ist, aber alles andere Sprache, wie man da mit Datenformaten und überhaupt auch mit Xcode umgeht, alle müssen sich noch Macintosh dazukaufen, um fürs iPhone auch zu entwickeln. Das wird einen riesen Boost auslösen. Und von daher denke ich mal, haben sie so einen Wert darauf gelegt, dass den Leuten auch klar wird, dass fürs iPhone-Programmieren bedeutet, dass man eben auch gleich...
Dass das nicht Macintosh, sondern OS X ist.
Genau, das ist einfach das Gleiche. Es ist nicht was anderes, sondern dass es natürlich schon Unterschiede gibt, aber im Prinzip verweisen sie auf die Gemeinsamkeit. Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine ganz sinnvolle Strategie, finde ich.
Also Synergie-Effekte.
Synergie-Effekte.
Ja, aber hier greift das und ich glaube, da kommen später auch noch mehr von denen, die halt keine Ahnung haben. Ich habe schon das Gefühl, Snow Leopard, wobei man jetzt mal noch ein bisschen erzählen muss, was es denn genau ist, aber es ist schon noch mehr dahintersteckt, als wir erstmal wissen. Die machen diesen Move ja nicht einfach so. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal erzählen, was denn Snow Leopard ist, weil wir schon mal anfangen haben, wir machen iPhone heute aus und zeigen es mal ein bisschen später.
Vielleicht können wir ja noch mal zusammenfassen, die meisten Leute werden es wahrscheinlich ihr schon gehört haben, es war World Wide Developer's Conference bzw. in diesem Moment, wo wir das aufnehmen, ist es sogar noch.
Die ist noch die ganze Woche lang.
Hat wie immer angefangen mit Steve Jobs auf der Bühne, der seine Famous-Kino-Urteilt, wobei er sich in zunehmendem Maße von seinen Schergen aushelfen lässt und irgendwie auch so ein bisschen zerbrechlich aussah.
Ja, da gibt es auch schon Reports, wo sie meinen, ob er schon wieder Krebs hat und so weiter, wo sich wieder Leute aufregen, was in einem Fall über die Gesundheit eines anderen…
Apple hat dementiert, er hätte sich nur irgendwas eingefangen.
Genau, muss man mal gucken, aber es wäre natürlich schon…
Aber er sah nicht mehr so frisch aus, er wird auch älter.
Er ist erst 50.
Ja, trotzdem älter, ich meine auch, wenn du 50 wirst, wirst du älter.
Er sah schon schmal aus.
Er war nicht so energetisch, fand ich, aber ich meine, das sind nun wirklich…
Aber dass sich die Leute da Sorgen machen, ist schon interessant, weil es ist ja wirklich, dass der eine Mann…
Der trägt eine Menge. Der trägt eine Menge. In dieser Zeit hat er sehr häufig darauf hingewiesen, was er doch für potente Leute in der zweiten Reihe hat.
Scott Forstall zum Beispiel, der ist relativ frisch. Ich weiß noch, vor ein paar Jahren hat er noch kleinere Sachen vorgeführt.
Der Chef von der iPhone Software Development.
Genau, vor ein paar Jahren war er noch so. Da musste er, weiß ich nicht, kleine OpenGL-Beschleunigungen vorführen oder so. Ich weiß nicht so genau.
Aber immerhin bist du auf die Bühne.
Naja, der machte jetzt auch schon länger auf der Bühne. Er ist jetzt öfter schon da gewesen.
Ja, das ist interessant, weil ich meine, wenn Steve Jobs mal abtreten müsste, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann braucht man ja nicht nur so diesen Visionär und Antreiber, sondern man braucht auch jemanden, der halt die Show machen kann.
Der die Show machen kann und der Tim Schiller ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Obwohl ich den eigentlich immer ganz lustig finde.
Aber er hat sich versprochen, dass es gehört.
Ja, mit... Und dann gleich so, oh nein, nein, nein, so war es nicht gemeint, wirklich nicht.
Bitte nicht klatschen.
Wir arbeiten super mit ihnen zusammen, aber Active Stink ist echt gut. Das könnte sich glatt halten.
Ich glaube, das ist durchgezogen.
Naja, also es war World Wide Developer's Conference Keynote und was wurde gezeigt? Ganz grob, es wurde gezeigt alles, was man erwartet hat, mit ganz wenigen Ausnahmen.
Es wurde überhaupt gar nichts über das noch bis dahin bekannte Mac OS X gezeigt, sondern eigentlich nur über das iPhone geredet.
Ja, es wurde über das iPhone 2.0 irgendwie mit noch ein paar neuen Features, also die neue Software, die ja auch für die alten iPhones gilt.
Also die haben das neue SDK vorgestellt, was aber schon im März eine Menge gezeigt wurde, also da war eine Menge Wiederholung der März iPhone SDK vorgestellt.
Genau, plus zwei, drei kleine Features.
Plus mehr Programme, plus dann am Ende, endlich, da ist der Kurs dann auch wieder nach oben. Vorher ist der Kurs ganz schön abgesagt. Ich bin ja noch mal schwitzen. Und dann ist der Kurs wieder nach oben, als dann irgendwie das iPhone 3G vorgestellt wurde.
Du meinst, der Kurs ist während der Keynote hoch und runtergegangen?
Ja, sicher, ganz zu gucken.
Echt?
Ja, weil es ist exakt, der ging runter, irgendwie ist es immer weiter runter, als die Software vorgestellt wurde, bis von 121 Euro bis auf 112 runter. Das sind 9 Euro, ist gar nicht so wenig. Und dann, wo das iPhone 3G vorgestellt ist, ist es gleich wieder hochgeschossen bis auf 118. Was denkst denn du, Mann?
Aber am Ende war er niedriger, oder?
Ja, ein bisschen, aber das ist normal. Der Hype ist vorher ziemlich hoch und die Erwartung kann man gar nicht erfüllen.
Das heißt, man braucht gar nicht die Keynote gucken, ob irgendwas Cooles angekündigt wird, sondern man schaut sich einfach nur den Kursverlauf an. Der Apple-Aktie wäre der Keynote, dann weiß man schon, ob man sich so dran schalten würde.
Das iPhone 3G wäre nicht vorgestellt worden, weil, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann wäre der Kurs ganz schön in den Keller gerutscht.
Das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, der Kurs ist auch in den Keller gerutscht, als sie ihr Best Quarter Ever angekündigt haben.
Ja, aber das liegt daran, weil mit dem Best Quarter Ever, das wissen andere schon ein paar Wochen vorher. Das ist deswegen, weil der Kurs auch so oben ist. Bis dann so eine normalen Leute wie wir das mitkriegen, ist alles schon längst gelaufen. Die sind da ein bisschen fixer mit den Aktien. Es ist ja alles irgendwie Spekulation und Spekulation auf die Zukunft. Deswegen ist der jetzige Kurs immer das, was sich in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten abbilden wird. Aber bei so einem Ereignis weiß ja keiner vorher irgendwas. Deswegen an so einem WWDC-Tag, dann siehst du den Kurs direkt.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem. Es wurde eigentlich fast nichts gezeigt und angekündigt, was nicht zumindest es geschafft hat, ein paar Tage vorher noch mal durch die Gerüchteküche gezogen zu werden.
Snow Leopard haben sie auch noch ein paar Tage vorher rausgefunden.
Genau, und auch dieses Mobile-Beam.
Aber GPS wusste bis dahin auch noch...
Das ist die einzige Überraschung. Also das hatte ich ja auch geblockt, so jetzt bei Mobile Max, GPS und die Evolution. Das halt eigentlich, das GPS war nicht sicher, das war das, was alle wollten, aber es war einfach nicht sicher, ob es kam. Und grundsätzlich eben, was ich ganz interessant finde, ist diese Ausrichtung auf Evolution, was sich auch bei dem iPhone's Regie schon schreibt, dass das Teil halt einfach mal im Prinzip dasselbe iPhone ist wie vorher auch. Sieht also nicht ganz anders aus.
Also ich hab mich schon auch währenddessen gewundert, wie man, okay es hat jetzt irgendwie UMTS, okay vielleicht ist GPS drin und was hat's noch? So viel kann es ja nicht sein. Was will man da so lange vorstellen? Aber Steve Jobs schafft es natürlich auch über nicht so riesengroße Änderungen oder die, die schon allen bewusst sind, irgendwie doch noch eine halbstündige Sache daraus zu machen und die dann trotzdem noch cool ist am Ende.
More affordable.
Weil so affordable ist es nämlich gar nicht.
Gut, jetzt sind wir schon bei WWDC, dann steigen wir doch einfach mal vorne ein. Steve wird alt, das haben wir schon erzählt. Diese 2.0-Geschichte. Also es wurde im Wesentlichen das erzählt, was schon bekannt war, dass halt Software-Update kommt, lalala und dass vor allem dieser ganze Exchange-Support mit drin ist. Also überhaupt dieser ganze Business-Kram mit reinkommt.
OpenVPN, Push-Services, dann halt...
Nee, OpenVPN ist nicht drin.
Nein, nicht OpenVPN, aber ein VPN halt. Also mehr VPN-Support über diesen Cisco.
Plus Cisco VPN, was interessanterweise nicht in Mac OS X drin ist. Bis heute nicht.
Noch nicht. Wundert mich ein bisschen, dass die es in den Server nicht reinmachen, dass man in den Server so klicken kann. Ich will einen VPN für mein iPhone haben. So klick, klick, klick. Das wäre eigentlich ziemlich praktisch. Aber ich hab's nur...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. VPN gibt's in Server. Es gibt bloß nicht Cisco VPN.
Cisco VPN, ich hab's mir mal ein bisschen angeschaut. Ich glaube, das ist nichts weiter als IPSEC mit Kerberos Keys.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was es ist, aber ich weiß, dass es so out of the box nicht funktioniert bei Mac OS X. Du musst halt noch diesen Cisco VPN-Kline installieren. Es gibt so ein paar Fischie-Oberflächentools, mit denen man sich das ein bisschen einfacher einrichten kann, aber eigentlich ist es ein bisschen so ein Pita.
Ich müsste hier noch mal gucken. Ich hab da schon ein bisschen rumgefummelt, die wollten sich noch nicht so richtig einigen.
Das ist doch das klassische Problem, was so Studenten haben an der Uni. Hier TU Berlin oder so, wenn du da hinlädst, musst du halt irgendwie Cisco VPN-Kline installieren. Totaler Sack, anstatt dass sie da halt irgendwie eine PPTP-Lösung machen.
Haben sie doch auch dabei. Nee, die iPhone.
Ja, natürlich haben sie PPTP, weil das haben sie auch beim Mac. Da müsste sie ja nichts Neues installieren. Aber wenn du halt einen Cisco VPN hast, Verstehe. Dann musst du halt neu installieren. Und das ist halt irgendwie bekloppt. Du kommst halt irgendwo hin und bevor du Internet kriegst, musst du halt erstmal was installieren. Aber woher willst du es denn kriegen ohne Internet? Das ist ja immer das elende Problem. Also ich hoffe, dass sie sich da mit Cisco irgendwie einig werden und das da auch noch mit reinschmeißen, weil das kann ja nur nicht das Problem sein. Und ansonsten haben sie eigentlich nur, mir fallen jetzt zwei Sachen ein, die eigentlich wirklich neu waren. Einerseits extrem begrüßenswert, dass sie jetzt auch PowerPoint-Dokumente anzeigen können, zumindest in ihrem E-Mail kleint.
Überhaupt alle. Keynote, Pages.
Und den ganzen iWork-Kram. Aber was er nicht gesagt hat, ist, ob man auch eine Keynote-Präsentation benutzen kann, richtig in Präsentationsmodus.
Wäre ein bisschen klein wahrscheinlich, oder?
Wieso klein? Da ist so groß, wie der Bildschirm halt ist. Und so ein iPhone kannst du halt auch nach einem Videoausgang. Also ich würde halt gerne mein iPhone mitnehmen. Also mein iPhone ist gut, ich habe ja immer noch keins. Du kriegst auch keins mehr.
Ist vorbei. Er holt nicht schnell eins. Also, es rennt schnell los.
Na mal gucken.
Weil gibt's also, naja, hier in Deutschland ja sowieso nicht, aber...
Das wäre ja auch ein interessanter Punkt, weil das habe ich mit meinem iPod auch schon gemacht. Da habe ich halt meine Präsentation einfach so als JPEG Slides rausgerendert und dann so als Fotos drauf gehabt. Hast du noch nicht, aber müsste ja gehen, weil es hat ja einen Videoausgang. Ich habe das mit meinem iPod 5G auch gemacht. Dann kann ich halt einfach Video ranstecken an irgendeinem Beamer und dann hast du halt so ein mobiles Präsentations-Device. Und das ist auch einfach, wenn du so am Tisch sitzt, reicht so ein iPhone-Screen für eine Präse gut aus. Zumindest wenn du nicht so eine Proto-Präse machst mit irgendwie 30.000 Bullet Points und 400 Schriften, sondern wie sich das halt gehört mit großer Schrift und der Reduktion aus Wesentlichen. Das geht schon, zumal wenn du da auch noch Videos mit drin hast. Das fände ich extrem cool.
Wahrscheinlich geht's nicht. Nehme ich mal mit der Software, die jetzt 2.0 ist, aber vielleicht kannst du sie am App Store kaufen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er jetzt noch kräftig dran geklopft wird und dass alle sagen, also wenn ihr eh schon Keynote macht, dann bitte auch gleich mal mit Präsentations-Modus, weil what's the fucking difference? Ich meine, es geht da eigentlich nur noch darum, dass da Fullscreen ist, aber keine Ahnung, ob dieses Quick Look Feature, was in Mac OS X ist, auch genau erzeugt wird.
Wenn sie Pages machen und den ganzen anderen, dann wird es wahrscheinlich auch die Präsentation gehen.
Also er hat es zumindest nicht gesagt oder gezeigt und wir werden es sehen.
Am 11. Juli kommt nämlich die neue Software für die alten iPhones, für for free. Und bei den neuen iPhones ist es dann gleich mit drauf.
Ja, die andere Sache war, ich meine, das andere Ding, was mir immer gefehlt hat bei dem iPhone, ist Java. Immer noch nicht, kein iChat, nix zu sehen, ja. Es gibt keinen Instant-Message.
Es wird im App Store sein.
Und dann, ja, gut, aber die Frage ist, was ist mit Background Ups so? Und Background Ups war ja so ein heißes Thema. Ich hab's gelesen, aber die Frage ist, was bitte, wovon reden die? Also sie haben jetzt ein Framework am Start oder ein Service, also da ist ein Server bei Apple, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
So hab ich es auch verstanden.
Und es geht ja darum, das Problem ist, Programme sollen nicht im Hintergrund laufen. Das kann ich irgendwie verstehen, weil sie sagen, Memory ist knapp, CPU ist knapp und wir wissen, was für ein Elend das ist auf dem Mac, wenn du da erstmal 3, 4, 5 Tools, die im Hintergrund irgendwas rumfugewerken, installiert hast, dann geht einfach die ganze Performance in die Knie. Da das iPhone nicht so viel hat und da sie eine Menge auf dieses Snappiness stehen, müssen sie da irgendeine Lösung machen. Und die Lösung, die sie jetzt gemacht haben, ist, dass das eigene Programm eben dann auch nicht laufen muss, sondern, und da wird es jetzt ein bisschen unklar, weil so viel haben sie ja nicht darüber erzählt, dass man dem Betriebssystem irgendwie sagt, dass man im Hintergrund Events empfangen will und die sollen halt von diesem Server, von dem mit dem man halt irgendwie verbunden ist, aber dann an diesen Apple Push Service Notification Server geschickt werden, der das dann wiederum ans iPhone schickt über eine permanent offene Verbindung. Was haben sie da? Haben sie da einen Server, der dann irgendwie 10 Millionen IP-Verbindungen offen hat zu jedem fucking iPhone auf diesem Planeten? Das kann aber auch nicht Ihr Ernst sein.
Das ist Apple egal, weil die haben ja ein Slash-8-Netz mit 16 Millionen Adressen.
IP-Adressen haben sie genug. Und dann soll man da drüber halt Badges, Textnachrichten oder Töne übertragen können, was halt auch einfach eine interessante Abstraktion ist. Das mag vielleicht für viele Programme ganz brauchbar sein, wie es ist eine neue Nachricht da. Aber mal ehrlich, wenn ich eine Java-Verbindung habe...
Aber es ist auch so, dass dann, wenn diese Nachricht kommt, wird ja nicht das Programm gestartet, sondern da wird nur halt diese kleine 1L-Symbol auf das Programm-Icon gelegt. Oder es kommt eine Textnachricht, so wie bei der SMS, dass man eine Nachricht irgendwie empfangen hat. Aber das Programm selbst wird gar nicht so richtig gestartet.
Ja, aber wie soll denn das bitte mit meinem Java-Server funktionieren? Der weiß erst mal von so einem Apple-Dienst nichts. Was erwarten die, dass man jetzt einen Java-Server baut, der mit Apple zusammenarbeitet?
Ja, da bräuchte man immer beide Seiten und das klappt halt für viele schon bestehende Protokolle nicht. Ich finde es auch ein bisschen komisch. Das hätte man auch anders lösen können.
Ja, und dann vor allem, was soll denn das? Dann gehen die Nachrichten dann da durch. Ich meine, die gehen dann bestimmt nicht verschlüsselt durch.
Die Nachrichten gehen ja wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht durch.
Authentifizierung, also ganz viele Fragezeichen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so der große Wurf ist.
Nein, klar, das ist auch nicht der große Wurf.
Aber warum kann ich denn mit meinem mobilen Device nicht chatten?
Kannst du doch. Du hast halt angelassen vorne.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Mal gucken. Also ich denke, Adium und so, die werden sicherlich den einen oder anderen Effort machen, um ihre Software auch aufs iPhone zu bringen. Aber das dauert noch eine Weile. Das hab ich zumindest selber gesagt.
Gibt es übrigens eine 1,3-W-Tafel-Adium-Font, die dich interessiert? Komm, ich muss dich runterladen.
Ja, hab ich sogar schon gemacht, aber ich hab's noch nicht gestartet. Ist da eigentlich irgendwas Tolles dran?
Nee, bisher nicht.
Aber immerhin funktioniert's, also es zickt bisher nicht rum.
Ja, und dann haben sie den App Store vorgestellt. Auch da war erst mal nicht viel Neues und ganz viele Programme gezeigt. Da war aber auch nicht viel Neues.
Super Monkey Boy, toll. Und hier so ein eBay-Auktions-Tool, gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich.
Ich denke, das ist überhaupt die Zukunft. Spezielle Clients für Websites mit einem gewissen Komplexitätsgrad.
Da sieht man auch eine interessante Entwicklung, weil eigentlich sagen ja alle, oh, die Web-Apps kommen. Also auch hier auf dem iPhone war's ja am Anfang, gab's ja nichts anderes als Web-Apps. So was ist nun? Es kommen die kleinen, nicht Web-Apps, die kleinen Spezialprogramme.
Web-Services, jetzt kommen die Clients für die Web-Services.
Weil, nämlich die viel effektiver sind.
Natürlich, viel effektiver und viel flexibler und viel pfiffiger auch, weil die natürlich so das eine oder andere tun. Also für so ein eBay-Tool zum Beispiel wäre dieser Push-Service ganz interessant. Für eBay lohnt sich das natürlich, das iPhone zu unterstützen, weil wenn halt ein neuer Bid ist auf dein Tool, was du verkaufst, oder wenn du nicht mehr der Bidder bist auf irgendetwas, wo du geboten hast, also wenn du nicht mehr der Höchstbietende bist, dann könnte halt dieser Push-Service ankommen.
Wahrscheinlich geht es mit dem iPhone schneller als mit Safari, weil Safari muss ja wieder die Seite aufmachen, den ganzen Zeug irgendwie holen und so. Und bei dem iPhone machst du nur schnell klick.
Ja und vor allem, du musst das Programm noch nicht mal laufen lassen und auf deinem Homescreen steht dann irgendwie so, eBay, es ist was passiert, check doch mal. Drückst du auf den eBay-Button und dann holt er sich die neuesten Informationen. Das könnte, glaube ich, ganz gut funktionieren. Nicht so ganz überzeugt haben mich diese medizinischen Anwendungen, aber das ist auch ein extrem vertikaler Markt. Ich weiß nicht, warum sie dem so viel Raum ein...
Der Businessmarkt. Damit wollen sie wahrscheinlich Businesskunden überzeugen, dass man halt für das Business, das halt toll ist für andere Firmen, die auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Lagerverwaltung oder sonstiges Zeug damit machen können.
Vertikale Anwendung. Ja, das kann gut passen. Das stimmt und dafür ist ja eigentlich, ich meine im Prinzip ist das iPhone ja dieser Tablet-Computer, von dem sie immer alle geredet haben. Das heißt, die anderen sind immer davon ausgegangen, dass man dann mit so einem DNA-Vier-Teil durch die Gegend rennt.
Weiß nicht, wer aus solchen Ideen kommt.
Na, Microsoft. Bill Gates propagiert auch schon seit zehn Jahren irgendwie, dass morgen der Tablet-Computer alles übernimmt und überrollt.
Aber es geht doch rein ergonomisch schon nicht. Also entweder liegt das Ding am Schreibtisch, dann ist es ein Laptop oder ich hab's halt mit dabei, dann ist es aber zu groß, dann ist es eher so was wie ein iPhone.
Sagt das Bill Gates. Also die Jobs hat das nie gekauft. Hat sich auf jeden Fall nicht durchgesetzt und ich glaube, das wird auch so schnell nicht passieren. Ich denke, dass das iPhone schon groß genug ist. Wobei ich nicht sagen will, dass es nicht auch eine Anwendung gäbe für etwas, was doppelt so groß ist für das iPhone.
Ja klar, aber das ist halt die Frage, wie weit man dann so ein Device mit sich rumschleppt.
Das ist in der Tat das Problem. Aber im Krankenhaus, wenn du jetzt wie Visite machst, also zur Visualisierung von Daten, manchmal will man auch mehr auf einen Blick sehen. Und ehrlich gesagt, diese Röntgen-Bilder, die sie da gezeigt haben und diese CT-Bilder, also ich bitte dich, 480 x 320 ist einfach keine nennenswerte Auflösung. Vor allem, um solche CT-Bilder zu interpretieren, brauchst du einfach einen extrem guten Monitor, der kalibriert ist.
Haben die auch mit riesenhohen Auflösungen. Also da ist nichts mit irgendwie die 480. Die brauchen ja so 3000 oder so.
Ja, nicht nur viele Pixel, sondern vor allem viele Graustufen. Also die Profi-Monitore, die da so in radiologischen Kliniken zum Einsatz kommen, die haben halt 16-Bit-Graustufen. Nee, aber ich kenne jemand, der in dem Bereich arbeitet und hat mir mal diese Dinger angeschaut und mich gewundert, was denn da, warum denn so ein Monitor, was weiß ich, das war irgendwie ein absurder vierstelliger Euro-Betrag, den das Teil gekostet hat und dann habe ich das mal hinterhergeklickt und dann wurde mir klar, was das Ding war. Ja, ja, das ist so Profikram. Andererseits mag das so für, also bei Radiologen ist das eine andere Geschichte als bei anderen Ärzten. Also für manche Bilder mag so ein Befund zum Nachschlagen.
Mehr Farben irgendwie, kann ja noch nie schaden.
Ne, sicherlich nicht. Also ich denke auch, dass in den vertikalen Marken eine Menge zu holen ist und deswegen haben sie es wahrscheinlich gezeigt. Aber ich glaube, was viel wichtiger ist, ist die Sache mit den Spielen. Ja, der Spielemarkt, der mobile Spielemarkt, der ist groß. Ich meine sogar auf dem iPod, wo du einfach nur so ein blödes Rad hast, werden Spiele für produziert.
Aber meinst du, es hat sich so richtig gelohnt für Apple mit den iPod-Spielen?
Naja, ich meine, jeder Kaufklick macht 5 Euro, davon landet bestimmt der eine oder andere bei Apple.
Ja klar, aber ob sich es halt auch von der Menge gelohnt hat, kann ich mir nicht so richtig vorstellen. Ich habe keine Spiele gekauft, ich habe mir nur die von einem kopiert und habe es ein paar Mal gespielt und dann waren sie irgendwann gelöscht, weil neu aufgesetzt oder was auch immer und dann hat es mich aber auch nicht weiter interessiert. Also so kurz mal reinschauen, das ist ganz nett, aber es reicht dann auch schon wieder.
Casual Gaming, also ich habe Spaß mit den Spielen auf dem iPod. Also nicht alles, was ich jetzt da so gekauft habe, ich habe mal das eine oder andere auch einfach so aus Interesse gekauft, weil ich halt mal gucken wollte, was da so geht.
Weil wir ja auch Early Adopter sind, ne?
Weil wir fucking Early Adopter sind und Early Adopter muss immer die Early Adopter-Punishment-Fee bezahlen. Die EAPF. Und die kommt, der ich übrigens beim iPhone bisher entgangen bin, das wundert mich so. Aber vielleicht bin ich jetzt auch einfach zu alt. Aber ich finde, das mit den Spielen ist schon cool.
Ich kann dir sagen, ob du zu alt bist. Du musst nur eine Frage beantworten.
Na, was kommt jetzt?
Wie viel Platz ist auf deiner Platte frei?
Mehr als 100G.
Ist die Platte nicht voll, bist du zu alt?
Das kann gut sein.
Ist so. Ich hab 10G frei. Früher war immer alles voll und ich musste immer irgendeinen Scheiß löschen, bevor ich irgendwie was Neues irgendwie raufmachen konnte.
Ich hab mir jetzt einfach so eine ganz gnadenlose 300G-Platte gekauft. Ich wollte einfach mal 100GB zum Atmen haben. Das fand ich geil. Ich muss sagen, ist super.
Gestern einer im Club ist da am Machen und meint, er ist da gerade irgendwie an so riesen Datenbanken sortieren und machen und tun, aber ist die Platte voll. Dann hol dir doch mal eine größere so. Meint, da geht nicht, ist schon ein 500er. Im Laptop.
Oha. Echt, es gibt 500er-Platten für den Laptop?
Der ist noch nicht zu alt. Kosten auch gar nicht so viel, kosten 170 oder was? Nee.
Was, die 500er kosten schon 170?
Oder was, die 250 und 170 kostet, ich weiß gar nicht. Also es ist verdammt billig. Aber wir gleiten ein bisschen ab.
Ein bisschen, genau. Abstore, Spiele. Also ich bin immer noch der Meinung, Spiele ist ein Markt, auf jeden Fall. Die Leute wollen spielen mit ihren Devices, das iPhone ist einfach super zum Spielen.
Das Schöne am Abstore ist ja auch, dass Apple, kann es ja total schnuppe sein, ob sich die Sachen lohnen, was die Leute da zusammen programmieren oder nicht. Und ein paar Firmen koden halt Müll, kaufen ein paar Leute, aber nicht genug. Und ein paar andere programmieren halt die Killer-Features und Apple verdient sich da dran mit dumm und dämlich, aber das regelt sich von alleine. Das ist eigentlich ganz schick. Dann werden wir ja sehen, was sich am Ende am meisten durchsetzt. Das wird man ja auch sehen an den Top-Spiele-Downloads, die die haben werden.
Das wird sehr interessant zu sehen, was sich überhaupt verkauft oder was ihr besser verkauft.
Ich hätte auch ein schickes iChat, würde ich mir auch shoppen, glaube ich. Und ein ganz schickes Terminal-Programm. Da gibt es zwar schon eins, das ist gar nicht so schlecht für umsonst bisher, also wenn man hier so ein ungeloggtes Jailbreak-Telefon hat, aber ich hätte gerne auch ein Terminal, was wirklich richtig war.
Du würdest auch bezahlen dafür?
Für bestimmte Sachen schon.
Würdest du auch für Adium bezahlen?
Na ja, sag ich ja, ein iShad will ich und ein Terminal.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist auch so eine Frage.
Was wäre, wenn jetzt so eine Open Source-Bude......kommt auf den Preis an?
Weil sie kontrollieren ja dann sozusagen...
Guck mal, wenn die für so ein Spiel wurde, die auch richtig lange dran sitzen.
Aber da könnte ja jeder andere dasselbe Programm auch als Developer anmelden und kostenlos und billiger verkaufen oder kostenlos anbieten.
Das ist Open Source, du musst auch schon noch eine Menge umcoden. So einfach geht es nicht.
Na gut, aber auch das wird ja dann am Ende Open Source sein.
Die werden sich da alle drängen. Jede dritte Firma kommt mit einem Location-Based Services Tool irgendwie, also hier Omni Group zum Beispiel, kommt mit Omni Focus, auch mit Friends Finder und all so im Schnickschnack. Meinen sie, kommt auch sofort, wenn der Store da ist. Also von dieser Sorte wird es richtig viel geben. Da ist eher so das Problem, dass es so viele gibt, dass keine richtige Community entstehen kann, weil es zu viele gibt. Weil es muss ja auch schon so die kritische Masse erreichen. Wenn es sich auf ganz viele Programmprotokolle irgendwie verteilt, dann wird es irgendwie nichts. Da muss man mal aufpassen, wer da irgendwie das Renten macht.
Was glaube ich ein echter Markt ist, sind auch so Begleiterprogramme. Also OmniFocus, das hoffe ich, gibt es ja schon auf dem Mac. Das will man dann halt auch noch auf dem...
OmniFocus gibt es schon?
Nicht? Ja, aber ich dachte, das wäre schon draußen. Ist es nicht?
OmniFocus?
Na, du redest doch von diesem Getting Things Done-Teil von der Omni Group, oder?
Hieß das Focus?
Nö, ich bin gerade nicht so sicher. OmniFocus, Personal Productivity and Peace of Mind steht da. Ja, klar, das ist sozusagen die Private Version von OmniPlan.
Hm, na, ich hab das OmniFocus, das auf dem iPhone kommen soll.
Wo war das, als das so ein Location-Ding sein sollte? Das haben sie letztes Jahr schon gesagt. Ja gut, ich meine, Location kann man überall mit reinbringen. Das kann schon sein, dass das da ein Thema ist. Aber das war schon letztes Jahr, als das iPhone angekündigt wurde, habe ich so ein Interview gesehen mit den Jungs von Omni Group und die meinten irgendwie, wollen wir haben für OmniFocus.
Hast du auch dieses Loop gesehen, wo man sich so finden kann und gucken kann, wer in der Nähe ist und so?
Ja, so halt so Social Network.
Aber der hat ja auch gesagt, so ein ganz jungischer Typ, der passt da gar nicht so richtig rein und zappelt da auch voll rum. Und die wollen ja zum Beispiel gar kein Geld haben. Wie verdienen die dann ihr Zeug?
Die verdienen derzeit wahrscheinlich ihr Geld beim Venture-Kapitalisten, wie das so ist, und versuchen, ihre Community aufzubauen und dann das System irgendwann einen Gewinn bringen, einen Google zu verkloppen. Nee, aber das ist, ich glaube bei Websites werden wir eine ganze Menge absehen, die kostenlos sind, so wie eBay oder irgendwie hier dieser AP-Typ, die Reporter, Associated Press, die halt dieses irgendwie gibt uns Stories und sagt uns, wo es passiert ist, Tools bauen. Also es gibt einen hohen Druck, auch Sachen kostenlos rauszutun oder der Kleinen für TypePad, für Blogging-Administration, das ist ein echter Grund, zu TypePad zu wechseln, für mich zum Beispiel.
Von unterwegs bloggen können.
Ja, vor allem einfach mal cool bloggen können, so dieses nicht mit irgendwelchen Interfaces umbauen.
Das ist ja vom Max genau so richtig, von unterwegs rum twitteren.
Ja, Twitterific ist auch schon unterwegs, also es gibt da für all diese ganzen, also alles, was Web-Dienste hat, ich denke wir werden wahrscheinlich auch nicht lange warten, bis Amazon so ein Tool draußen hat, wie eBay, nur dass die da nicht auf der Bühne standen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Das kann natürlich auch passieren, das wird auch spannend zu sehen, wie Apple da reagiert, wenn Amazon erstmal da den Music Store direkt da drauf packt und vor allem, ob die Programme die Möglichkeit haben, dann auch lokal runterzuladen. Das wird nämlich wahrscheinlich nicht so ohne weiteres gehen.
Bisher, kommt man ja noch nicht wieder dran, das lohnt ja gar nicht, also irgendwas drauf zu speichern oder...
Können die Programme irgendwie Files ablegen? Können die in die Musiklibrary was reinscheißen?
Ob sie das reinschreiben können, weiß nicht, aber sie können schon Programme ganz normal aus dem File-System zugreifen und man kommt über Apis zum Beispiel auch an die Bilder ran und so weiter und so fort. Das geht wahrscheinlich auch an die Musik.
Aber eher so read-only, nicht so zum rein werfen. Das wäre ja sozusagen optimal für so ein Store wie Amazon. Du kaufst direkt auf dem iPhone das Teil, lädst es runter, wirfst es in die Library rein und ab da singt es dann halt auch mit iTunes weiter.
Das geht ja schon eh nicht. Hast du jemals versucht, so einen Song normal von einem iPhone oder von einem iPod wieder runterzukriegen? Keine Chance, außer mit so Spezial-Tools halt.
Naja, klar, na gut, aber wenn es da halt ein definiertes API gibt, wenn man was hinzufügen kann, aber ich habe da auch arge Zweifel, ob sowas von Apple einfach gemacht werden wird. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ach ja, was ich auch noch interessant fand, TomTom.
Ja, habe ich auch gelesen.
Hat schon angekündigt, dass sie kommen. Das macht natürlich super Sinn. Also das ist...
Ich habe ja einen TomTom Rider für mein Motorrad. Das ist ja Linux-basiert und die Software ist so, naja, wie man sich das halt so vorstellen kann, als Mac-User wenn man nicht von einem Mac kommt.
Aber ich finde die TomTom Software gut. Echt? Also die kann man bedienen. Also sie ist viel besser als vieles, was ich sonst noch so gesehen habe.
Das kann sein.
Ich finde die TomTom Software gut. Ich kann einfach irgendeinen TomTom nehmen, obwohl ich keine... Also ich habe selber keins, aber dann komme ich bei jemand anderem ins Auto, wo ein TomTom ist. Ich begreife das relativ fix und ich finde auch die ganze, wie sie was anzeigen und so weiter, das ist prima.
Also ein paar Sachen stören mich irgendwie, dass man, wenn man klickt, immer gleich wieder zum Hauptschirm zurückkommt und sich wieder den ganzen Weg durchfummeln muss und so.
Klar, das ginge noch besser, aber es ist nicht so, dass man es nicht benutzen kann. Aber wenn das Ding in dem eigentlichen Tracking-Modus ist, funktioniert das gut. Die Stimmen sind so halbwegs brauchbar. Naja, also mit diesen üblichen Sachen irgendwie so in 300 Metern. Sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht, damit sie es doch immer noch wieder aufs Display draufhauen. Aber, naja, und sie haben ordentliches Material, das ist das Entscheidende. Und ich frage mich, wie sie es machen. Wenn sie jetzt die Applikation runterladen, holen sie sich dann sozusagen die aktuelle Location und laden dann dynamisch das Datenmaterial, was sie brauchen. Wenn du sagst, ich will da und dahin, dass sie dann wirklich einen Server-Request machen, weil sie werden ja sicherlich nicht auf das iPhone das ganze Karten entgegenpackt haben.
Ich hab ja auf meinem TomTom ganz Europa drauf und es ist irgendwie ein Gigabyte. Das heißt, sie müssten es dann aufs iPhone zählen, was aber nicht das Problem ist. Weil sie sagen ja, bis 10 MB kann man auch über GSM oder UMTS runterladen.
Das Programm selber wird nicht so groß sein.
Das Programm selber nicht, nee. Aber die Daten müssen ja auch installiert werden.
Ja, dann shoppst du einfach deine Maps. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das Programm einfach, was weiß ich, sogar kostenlos anbieten. Also jetzt mal so als Idee könnten sie machen, kostenlos oder zumindest extrem billig. Aber dann, und sie nehmen ja Kohle für die Maps an, dann kommt das Ding sozusagen ohne Map. Oder du kriegst nur, keine Ahnung, irgendeinen regionalen Bereich oder sonst irgendwas. Und dann kaufst du halt Karten dazu. Ja, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Anwendung. Ja, was ich noch sehr interessant fand, ist ja diese, ihre Antwort auf die Problematik der Distribution von Anwendungen. Also neben dem Upstore gibt es die Möglichkeit für Enterprises, das zu machen. Das heißt, wenn du eine große Firma bist, du sagst, wir möchten da mal unseren Fuhrpark mit iPhones ausstatten.
Wenn man halt ein eigenes Programm haben will, was nicht für alles, sondern nur für halt die Mitarbeiter.
Dann kassierst du da irgendwie eine Lizenz und darfst deinen eigenen Upstore sozusagen fahren.
Na, über iTunes installiert man die dann.
Bist du sicher? Ich, okay, jetzt bin ich mir grad nicht mehr so ganz sicher. Ich hatte noch so im Ohr, dass sie dann selber... Das ist wahrscheinlich viel zu aufwendig. Auf jeden Fall meldet man die iPhones selber an und dann kriegt man die Programme quasi auch personalisiert.
Ja, aber die sind ja alle signaliert irgendwie wohl.
So ist es ja grundsätzlich. Das heißt, ihr Fairplay-DAM, was sie für Musik verwendet haben und für Videos......benutzen jetzt auch ihre Programme. Was würdest du jetzt sagen?
Aber in dem Fall sehe ich das gar nicht so. In dem Fall sage ich nicht, dass sie evil sind. Das stört mich gar nicht. Weil? Weil es auch so ein bisschen das iPhone sauber hält vor dem größten Müll.
Das stimmt schon. Man kann halt nicht irgendwas installieren.
Genau, das macht das alles ein bisschen aufeinander.
Kannst du dich über Bluetooth mal eben so ein Virus einfahren.
Genau, da macht das schon Sinn. Aber ich hätte schon auch gerne meine eigenen Programme draufgeschoben. Aber es ist ja genau, wo soll man vorher wissen, ob es das eigene oder von jemand anderes kommt. Deswegen wird es natürlich schon ein bisschen schwer. Aber evil würde ich die deswegen nicht nennen.
Nee, ich finde es auch eher technisch interessant. Auch interessant ist ihre Lösung für das Problem mit lokaler Peer Group. Ihr Beispiel war Uni. Der Professor, der …Genau, das heißt der Professor muss sich dann aber trotzdem noch so einen 99 Dollar Developer Account klicken, kann aber dann bis zu 100 iPhones drauf eintragen.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob er das machen muss.
Ich frage mich bloß, ob man mit seinem iPhone auf mehrerer Leute Developer Liste draufstehen kann. Also was ist, wenn ich in zwei solchen Peer Groups bin? Weil das ist schon nicht ganz, also es ist vielleicht jetzt nicht so das Übliche, aber mein Gott, ein Student hat halt mehrere Professoren. Wenn jetzt alle Professoren anfangen, iPhone-Programme zu distributieren im kleinen Rahmen. Also da bin ich gespannt, ob das wirklich die richtige Antwort ist.
Es ist natürlich auch mit der Sicherheit und mit dem Luxus der Bedienung, wie sagt man, zwei Seiten der Medaille oder...
Ja, so sagt man das.
So sagt man das.
Es ist immer ein Problem. Also kannst du eine das eine haben oder das andere, aber meistens nie beides. Und naja, die haben halt eher auf die Sicherheit gesetzt. Was ich aber verstehe, da finde ich die gar nicht so ibel. Okay, aber genug Software oder fällt dir noch was ein?
Nö, zum Upstore und so, ich denke ich mal, da fällt mir wenig weiter ein. Aber wenn wir jetzt in der Reihenfolge der WWDC bleiben, wir können jetzt auch so einen Spannungsbogen aufbauen. Ja, die Leute hören jetzt diesen Podcast und denken sich, iPhone, iPhone, iPhone, ich will jetzt endlich das 3G-iPhone.
So war es ja in der WWDC auch.
Genau.
Der Kurs war schon am sinken.
Und wir waccheln einfach gemütlich durch die langweiligen Themen. Und jetzt kommen wir auch noch mit dem großen Obergainer. Oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was kam denn da noch?
Danach kam Mobile Me, was ja Mr. John Grober sehr akkurat vorhin gesagt hat.
Jetzt kommt mein Apple is Evil.
Oh ja, ja, ja. Also was ist Mobile Me? Mobile Me ist ein Rebranding von.mec.
Exchange for the rest of us.
Sie bauen aber neue Features ein. Exchange for the rest of us. Ich meine, an sich ist das ein cooler Ansatz. Sie bieten einen Service, in dem ein Versprechen auch endlich mal erfüllt wird. Also auf jeden Fall ist es Easy Syncing. Es ist wie so wie, Syncing, bloß du musst halt nicht mehr dein Computer sagen, jetzt synkt mal wieder, oder synkt mal alle 10 Minuten, sondern Syncing funktioniert so irgendwie automatisch.
Das ist total cool.
Push heißt das jetzt.
Und das ist an sich ganz cool. Es ist für Mail, es ist für Kalender und es ist für... Adressdaten. So, und was ich aber interessant finde, ist, wieder mal keine Aussage zur Security. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Daten nur verschlüsselt bei Apple durchgehen, weil Syncing heißt ja auch...
Also cool wäre es natürlich, wenn sie es verschlüsselt und dort verschlüsselt ablegen und Apple es gar nicht irgendwie rankommt. Aber ich denke mal nur, dass der Transport verschlüsselt ist, aber nicht der Inhalt.
Hoffentlich ist der Transport verschlüsselt.
Das denke ich schon.
Das denken wir aber, wissen tun wir es nicht. Warum sagen sie es nicht? Also ich meine...
Weil es selbstverständlich ist.
Ach, selbstverständlich. Ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher.
Die machen da ein bisschen harte TPS, alles gut.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ein interessanter Ansatz. Das kostet immer noch 99 Dollar im Monat. Ich weiß ja nicht...
Was mich da dann stört ist, warum kann... Also ich meine, jeder, der so ein iPhone hat, also 95 Prozent der Leute, die ein iPhone haben, haben irgendwie den passenden Rechner dazu. Also von mir aus Windows oder halt Mac mit irgendwie iTunes, dass ich nicht nach Hause kommen kann. Mein iPhone merkt alles klar, es ist zu Hause. Bei der WLAN-Station wird es gefunden und synkt dann gleich über WLAN. Ich muss gar nichts machen, ich kann nicht mal das iPhone aus der Tasche holen.
Direkt mit deinem Computer?
Genau, das muss gar nicht viel sein, nämlich nur Adressbook und eigentlich nur noch Kalender, weil meine Mails und auch wie der meisten Leute, denke ich mal, sind auf einem IMAP-Server. Es ist sowieso schon gebackupt. Meine Mails muss ich nicht backupen. Also dafür ist ja ein IMAP-Server da. Und das würde mir schon reichen. Und ich würde wahrscheinlich auch, wenn der Service von Apple, dieses neue Mobile Me, nicht so teuer wäre, dann würde ich es vielleicht auch interessant finden, nämlich 10-20 Dollar im Jahr, weil meine Mails müssen ich nicht hin, dann würde ich sagen, nee, brauch ich nicht. Aber für 100 ist es zu viel.
Na also so 5 Dollar im Monat.
Fünf?
Nee, blödsinn. Das bin ich nicht hier.
Acht und ein halb oder so.
99 durch 12. Sowas konnte man früher mal im Kopf.
Acht und ein halb, ne?
Acht und 25. Dollar. Also Euro, meinte ich. Entschuldigung. Wie ist denn der aktuelle Kurs? Acht, 25, ja, 5,33 Euro, genau, das war das, was ich im Kopf hatte.
Na gut, aber die werden das ja nicht eins zu eins umrechnen, dann wird ja hier... Also, die werden es nicht umrechnen und die werden es wieder eins zu eins machen. Höchster Scheiß. Also, bestimmt hier 100 Euro kosten.
Ich weiß nicht. Gibt es überhaupt ein spezielles Deutschlandangebot dafür oder ist das nicht einfach der amerikanische Service, den du auch hier...
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, da gibt es nur einen Preis.
Aber so oder so, mir wäre das zu teuer. Okay.
Ja, aber für manche andere Leute, ich meine, wenn du jetzt... Guck mal, jetzt hast du dieses Problem. Rechner zu Hause und ein Laptop, was weiß ich. Und vielleicht haben die Leute ja dann auch wirklich noch ein iPhone. So, und jetzt wollen sie einfach ihre Adressdaten und ihre E-Mail und die wollen auch ein E-Mail-Account haben.
Klar, für so, da lohnt es sich dann schon. Wenn sie dann den Account gleich mitkriegen, dann die Mails auch gleich dort liegen, also der Mobile Me sozusagen nennen, iMap Service, da macht es ja Sinn, dann liegen die Mails ja auch wirklich da und wenn du deine restlichen Daten noch ablegst dort, dann hast du ja auch ein bisschen mehr Service. Aber für Leute, die schon einen iMap-Server haben, und das sind halt auch viele, die schon ein Business haben so, Business, Firmen, andere...
Business hat dann Exchange am Start. Beziehungsweise, wenn das Business sowas noch nicht hat, können sie sich dann auch demnächst OS X Server kaufen, wo dieselben Dienste drauf sind.
Verstehe, das heißt, die eine Seite ist schon komplett abgedeckt über Exchange Server?
Es gibt das, was es heute schon gibt, im Business, Exchange. Dann gibt es für den Personal User Mobile Me. Dazwischen kannst du dir dann ein OS X Server kaufen, wo du die gleichen Dienste drauf hast. Ob das dann wirklich genauso out of the box funktioniert, ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar. Aber sie haben halt dieses CalDAV, Kalendersharing. Sie haben dann dieses neue CardDAV, also die Spezifikation, Adressbuch über WebDAV, so wie sie jetzt Kalender über WebDAV und iDisc schon über WebDAV machen, halt alles HTTP-basiert. Das macht irgendwie Sinn. Und Apple bietet auch diesen CardDAV-Server im Übrigen als Open Source an, künftig.
Also ich hätte gerne Mobile Me Mini nur für Adressbuch und alles außer Mail zum Beispiel.
Aber ist doch auch evil. Dann lesen sie doch deine Adressbucheinträge.
Naja, so gesehen hast du recht. Also eigentlich sollten sie mal den Service rausdrücken, dass ich mir den selber installieren kann.
Ja, und der heißt, glaube ich, OS X Server Schneeleo.
Da meinst du so was dabei, dass ich mein iPhone zu meinem Schneeleo sünden kann?
Soweit ich das verstanden habe.
Also das würde ich dann wiederum cool finden. Und dann ist es mir initial einmalig auch eine Menge Geld wert. Also mehr auf jeden Fall. Aber ich mag so laufende Kosten nicht. Das würde ich dann einmal irgendwie mir zusammen shoppen oder wie auch immer. Und dann aufsetzen und dann das wäre schick. Und dann auch gleich mit einem VPN mit dabei. Das wäre toll.
Na gut, VPN hast du ja im Prinzip heute schon auf deinem Mac.
Nee, für mein iPhone mein ich.
Achso.
Dass mein iPhone zu meinem OS X Server gleich irgendwie die Verbindung macht.
Ja, aber das müsste jetzt auch schon gehen, wenn PPTP im iPhone drin ist. Ist es doch, oder? Du hast bei OS X Server, hast du PPTP als Standarddienst. Da sagst du, schaltest du an. Hast du auch bei der Mac OS X als Standarddienst, der PPTP Server? Es gibt ein kleines Tool, das heißt iVPN. Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, aber grundsätzlich funktioniert's. Hab ich gehört. Und da startest du und der konfiguriert dir deinen PPTP Server auf deinem normalen Mac OS X Client.
Das musst du mir zeigen nachher.
Ja, iVPN heißt das.
Ich hab nämlich zu Hause noch einen Mac, der steht da so rum und dann könnte ich irgendwie...
Genau, dann kannst du das nämlich damit machen. Also sowas gibt's schon. So, und hier zu der Information. Wir greifen mal ein bisschen vor. Und es gibt also, also muss man sehen, was am Ende dabei rauskommt. Aber ich glaube, das ist ihre Strategie. Sie bauen Mac OS X Server auf als Exchange-Konkurrent. Für Small Business, wo sie eben eine Chance haben, realistisch auch noch mit reinzukommen. Und da muss man sehen, wie gut das ist. Ich habe jetzt hier mit 10.5.2 Server, muss ich dazu sagen, ein bisschen rumgespielt, hatte da so ein bisschen Raub kopiert, um mal einfach zu testen. Beim 10.5.3 Update ist mir dann die geraubte Seriennummer dann auch wieder entwichen. Also habe ich es gleich wieder geputzt. Dann durfte ich sozusagen nicht zu Ende testen. Na ich wollte halt mal ausprobieren. Ich kaufte auch nicht mir so einen Server für 500 Euro, um dann festzustellen, dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Aber ich habe diesen blöden Kalenderserver nicht zum Laufen bekommen. Ich habe es einfach nicht verstanden. Ich habe jetzt auch nicht stundenlang investiert das Manual zu lesen, muss ich zugeben. Sicherlich geht es irgendwie, aber es war nicht so out of the box, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Hat doch schon einer letztendlich, da hat doch jemand schon mal im Forum geschrieben, wie es geht, oder?
Hat jemand? Es gab ein paar Tipps und ich habe den einen oder anderen auch ausprobiert, aber ich habe derzeit leider ein bisschen zu wenig Zeit, um diesen Ding wirklich intensiv nachzugehen, also habe ich dann einfach meinen Mac OS X normal auf den Mac Mini draufgespielt, dann funktioniert das auch mit dem Rest.
So, dann, so, one more thing.
One more thing. Achso, es gibt übrigens noch einen Aspekt bei Mobile Me. Das läuft auch mit Windows. Mac ist ein Dienst für Mac OS X gewesen. Mobile Me ist für iPhone, Mac OS X und Windows.
Wie Windows?
Na ja, du kannst auch mit Outlook drauf zugreifen und machst den Push auch in deinen Outlook-Adressbook und so weiter. Also du hast eine Syncing, die halt plattformübergreifend ist. Das denke ich mal ist eigentlich fast noch das wichtigste Detail. Sie attackieren mit Mobile Me nochmal Windows. Also sie gehen nicht nur mit iTunes und Safari drauf, sondern jetzt bieten sie halt auch das erste Mal einen Webservice an oder so einen Kollaborations-Service an, der halt auch unter Windows läuft.
Das ist also eine Attack of Exchange eigentlich.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, es ist eher eine Attacke auf Windows-User, um sie sozusagen zu motivieren, sich einen Macintosh dazu zu kaufen. Weil du hast ja immer das große Problem mit wie kriege ich meine Daten von A nach B. Und dann hast du auch die Windows, wo noch nicht mal VK30 unterstützt wird und mit den Umlauten, das hat irgendwie alles scheiße usw. Und die Leute haben halt alles in ihrem Exchange oder in ihrem Outlook drin. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, ach ja, hier gucke mal, 99 Dollar zahlst du mobile Mi und dann hast du das in Nullkommanix auch auf deinem frisch gekauften MacBook Air und auf deinem kleinen Mac Mini, den die dir als Multimedia-Station in der Sucht gestellt hast.
Das ist doch klar, weil die Leute ja erst mal die beiden Rechner parallel haben.
Genau, so. Und damit erleichterst du ihnen sozusagen die Transition. Und dann eben auch noch mit dieser iDisk, das funktioniert dann halt auch unter Windows. Sprich, du hast Datei-Sharing im Web, du hast Datei-Sharing auf deinem Windows, du hast es auf deinem, also du hast alle Dienste im Web, du hast alle Dienste, auch Kalender und Mail, auf Windows, auf dem iPhone und auch auf deinem Macintosh, den du gekauft hast. Und das ist natürlich auch ein gutes Transitionstool an der Stelle.
Ja, 100 Euro.
Ja, das ist schon, das ist schon cool. Es ist nicht so für uns, aber es ist so für die anderen.
Aber was ist denn für mich? Ich will auch was.
Für dich ist, du kannst dich mit Mac OS X Server hinsetzen und solange rumformeln, bis du den Kalenderserver gestartet bekommst. Na ja gut, aber das ist im Prinzip das Angebot. Das existiert schon. Na gut, one more thing, jetzt gehen wir mal auf das 3G, wa?
Jetzt gehen wir mal zu Hardware hier, genau.
Da ist es.
Neues iPhone.
Neues iPhone, gibt's jetzt. Und?
Das ist gar nicht so anders.
Nee, hab ich auch, hab ich das nicht gesagt? Ich weiß nicht, ich hab's auf jeden Fall gedacht. Nachhinein kann man ja immer, ne?
Ja, gib nichts an.
Aber es war so, meine Erwartung war eigentlich, dass ich das iPhone selbst so nicht groß unterscheide von dem alten, und so ist es ja eigentlich auch gekommen. Und meine Hoffnung war, dass es GPS hat. Aber ich war mir nicht so sicher, ob sie es wirklich machen.
Mir auch nicht.
Weil sie ja auch nach GPS-Engineers gesucht haben und so weiter in ihrer Stellenbörse. Aber offensichtlich könnte sich schon jemand damit aus. Und jetzt gibt's das halt auch. Mal gucken, ob's ist. Aber wie auch in unserer letzten Sendung spekuliert, machen sie AGPS. Was jetzt nicht so ein Big Deal ist, weil letzten Endes ist es halt trotzdem noch ein GPS-Empfänger. Mit dem AGPS sind sie halt schneller im Fix.
Ja, schneller im Fix sind sie doch sowieso, weil sie doch ihre Location auch so schon... Sie machen jetzt ja alle drei Sachen. Also über WLAN-Station, über Funkzellen und über GPS halt ist.
Die Frage ist, ob sie die eine Information auch...
Nutzen, um einen Fix für den GPS zu kriegen? Schlau wär's ja.
Könnte sein. Es gab so eine Demo von dem GPS, also bei der Keynote, da hat er so auf irgendwie... Tracking gescheitert.... und dann war da so ein erst großer Kreis, dann ein kleinerer Kreis.
Ein pulsierender Kreis, ja, hab ich auch gesehen.
Nee, danach erst hat er pulsiert. Es war halt... Also ich hatte so den Eindruck, als erstes nimmt er die Funkzelle, da bist du in etwa im Umkreis 5.000 Meter, dann kommt irgendwie Skyhook, da bist du wahrscheinlich irgendwie da, und dann kam dann erst der GPS-Fix. Aber das war jetzt auch, ich meine, bei so einer Präsentation...
Weiß man nicht.
Weiß man's nicht.
Aber sie haben auf jeden Fall einen Tracking-Mode mit drin. Das hat nicht mal mein TomTom. Mein TomTom kann nicht mittracken, das ist total lame.
Wie dein TomTom kann nicht mittracken? Wie?
Na nee. Was? Also da kannst du nicht sagen, nimm mal jetzt auf, ich fahre jetzt irgendwie mal ein paar hundert Kilometer mit meinem Moped durch die Gegend.
Ach so, man ist aufzeichnen, wo man langgefahren ist? Hat er das gesagt?
Haben wir doch gesehen. Wie?
Was haben wir denn gesehen?
Wo er an dieser Zixas-Straße langgefahren ist, hat er doch abgespielt.
Ach so, na für die Demo. Für die Demo.
Ach so.
Ich glaube, ich erwarte nur, das war nur eine Demo, zu zeigen, wie es ist, wenn du wirklich diese Straße entlangfährst.
Ob sie da wirklich einen Tracking-Speicher haben? Aber das ist eine Sache von einer kleinen Applikation im Store. Weil an die Location kommen sie alle ran. Tracking kannst du einfach starten. Also ich glaube, das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch schnell gehackt, wenn man den Versprechungen glauben darf, wie einfach so eine Applikation zu erstellen ist. Du hast ja gesehen, Scott Forstl hat ja gezeigt, wie man schnell mit Xcode so ein Tool macht. Wie man Adresscode und Location zusammenführt.
Die Standardvorführungen, die sind immer mit einem Interface-Bilder, machen wir jetzt so schön einfaches. Aber so ein bisschen getrickst. Ja, wir ziehen hier mal unseren vorgefertigten Code rein. Es ist so, als wenn der Bio-Lag kocht, weißt du, ja, ich habe da mal was vorbereitet und du weißt irgendwie von nichts.
Das stimmt schon. Das stimmt schon. Aber es ist für einen halbwegs erfahrenen Programmierer kein großes Ding. Es wird nicht lange dauern und du hast solche Tracking-Tools einfach dabei.
Das soll schnell gehen, ja. Zur Not mache ich mir das selber.
Im Übrigen möchte ich gerne dieses Core-Location, dieses Framework, hätte ich auch ganz gerne für OS X.
Ich glaube, es kommt auch. Dafür versuchen sie vielleicht einen GPS-Engineer, weil es jetzt demnächst in allen Laptops drin ist. Ja, wieso nicht? Die Zeit wird zwar langsam. Wozu schießen denn hier so milliardenteure Satelliten nach oben, früher nur noch Galileo ein, damit du irgendwie einen Navi extra in der Tasche haben musst? Ich meine, es wird demnächst in jedem Telefon drin sein und wieso auch nicht im Laptop und überhaupt überall. In jeder Kamera wird es drin sein und ist ja auch schon in ganz vielen. Das neue iPhone wird übrigens die Blockage im Bild.
Warum sollte nicht ein 2000 Euro Laptop sowas haben? Da hast du recht.
Genauso wie da eigentlich auch eine UMTS-Dingskarte da rein gehört.
Das ist ein guter Klauschutz.
Da gibt es schon auch so ein, zum Beispiel wir sind wieder bei TomTom, bei TomTom gibt es so ein Gerät, die haben sich irgendwie mit Vodafone oder O2 oder was auch immer geeinigt. Da gibt es so einen kleinen Stick, der passt in Zigarettenanzünden oder so. Ich muss jetzt ein bisschen ins Blaufasen. Im Forum beschweren sie ja immer, aber mir fällt es gerade so ein. Und das ist so ein Gerät mit einer GSM-Karte, die kriegst du extra von TomTom mit dazu und die ist auch nur dann, um irgendwie Daten zu holen. Sie haben da so ein Deal mit zum Provider und darüber machen sie dann ihre Kartenabgleichung. Das heißt, du musst ja gar nicht mehr über dein Telefon oder sonst wie kompliziert machen und dann sind deine Anrufe gesperrt oder wie auch immer, sondern es kriegt gleich eine eigene Karte, was soll's.
Über eine SIM-Karte, über eine GSM, Daten holen.
Genau, es gibt also Geräte, TomTom, so ein Navi, der seine eigene SIM-Karte mitbringt, weil TomTom sagt, alles klar, wir haben hier so ein Deal mit so einem mobilen Provider und das kostet euch halt irgendwie 5 Euro im Monat oder was weiß ich, dafür, dass euer Navi dann immer aktuell am Start ist. Und so könnte ich es mir eigentlich auch gut für das Laptop vorstellen.
Ja, stimmt.
Und dann genauso gut halt mit GPS, das muss da alles rein, ich meine, ich will wissen, wo ich bin, ich will immer Netz haben und Kompass fehlt halt noch für die Richtung. Also beim Laptop vielleicht nicht so unbedingt, aber für ein iPhone wegen der Kamera und so wäre das schon cool. Dann wird man nicht nur weiß, wo man aufgenommen hat, sondern auch noch in welche Richtung.
Und Beschleunigungs-Sensor können sie auch noch gebrauchen, das machen sie doch auch bei diesen teuren TomToms. Du kannst auch halt auch noch einen Tunnel, wenn du im Tunnel fährst, keine Satellitenverbindung hast, dann merkt er, dass er dich vorwärts bewegt hat. Genau, da gucken sie dann auf ihren Beschleunigungs-Sensor und sagen, ah, der fährt dann etwa in die Richtung. Aber hab ich noch nicht ausgerührt, ob es wirklich funktioniert. Ich verstehe sowieso die TomTop-Webseite nicht. Ich hab schon vor ein paar Tagen mal versucht, mich für ein Gerät zu entscheiden und diese TomTom-Webseite ist völlig beknackt. Grauenhaftes Marketing-Gefasel. Also warum sie denn nicht einfach mal klare Fakten erzählen können?
Die können ihre Produkte nicht so richtig voneinander unterscheiden.
Da sind so vier Geräte oder fünf Geräte so in der näheren Auswahl, da möchte ich die irgendwie vergleichen und dieses blöde User-Interface besteht darauf, dass ich maximal nur drei Geräte miteinander vergleichen kann. Was soll das denn? Oder einfach mal so eine Produktmatrix aufmachen, wo einfach mal alle drauf sind. Einfach ein PDF-Download kann doch so schwerlich sein.
So eine Seite, wo man irgendwie rechts unten auswählen kann.
Ja, es muss einfach immer alles dieser blöde Flash-Kack sein und so. Da müssen sie echt nochmal ran. Aber sie haben immerhin ihre Software jetzt für den Mac nochmal irgendwie verbessert.
Haben die bei Heise geschrieben, habe ich runtergeladen und habe festgestellt, dass es nur eine bessere Version ist von dem, was ich schon hatte, da war Heise ein bisschen hinterher.
Ja, es war nicht wirklich neu, sondern nur aktualisiert.
Aber wo war ich wirklich noch dran?
Heise entdeckt den Mac! Ja, das ist so. Die stellen jetzt fest, oh, es gibt die Software auch für andere Computer als für unsere Windows-Büchsen. Wir tun ihnen wahrscheinlich total unrecht jetzt gerade. Alle Redakteure haben wahrscheinlich schon so einen langen Mac zu Hause. Sie dürfen nicht, wir müssen Windows bedienen.
Zurück zum neuen iPhone.
Genau.
Sie haben, muss man erst mal sagen, Steve hat fünf wichtige Punkte vorgestellt. Kopfhörerprobleme waren nicht von den wichtigen Punkten, aber das haben sie auch gefixt.
Aber das war bei mir ganz oben auf der Liste.
Das war ein bisschen nervig, gab es aber Adapter für. Aber erstmal hat es UMTS, muss man sagen, mit einem dicken neuen Chip von Infineon, der auch Standards bis zu 7,2 MBit kann.
Download. HSDPA.
Genau.
Keine Aussage über HSUPA.
Wenn man mal bei deren Specs guckt, dann sieht man sowas.
Was unterstützt keiner?
Das kann der Chip, aber das machen die Provider noch nicht. Ich hab was gelesen von 1,3 MBit.
Manche, also die, die jetzt UMTS überhaupt erst nachrüsten in ihren Netzen weltweit, die gehen natürlich gleich auf 7,2. In Deutschland war es halt erst mal die Hälfte.
Aber haben die es auch schon freigeschaltet? Ich meine, dann machst du ja die ganze Leitung platt.
Weiß ich nicht. Maximum, was ich bei O2 rausgeholt habe, waren so 400 Kilobyte pro Sekunde. Ja, aber für 400 Kilobyte pro Sekunde… Na, das ist eigentlich…
Kilobyte, ja?
Kilobyte pro Sekunde.
Das hört sich ganz stark nach 3,6 MBit. Das wäre ja schon mal ganz schön fett. Das ist genau die Hälfte von diesen 7,2 MBit, weil das war nämlich vorher der Standard. Diese 7,2 MBit ist jetzt nochmal verdoppelt worden.
Genau, aber worüber sie nichts gesagt haben, und da muss ich jetzt auch glatt nochmal in die Specs gucken von dem neuen iPhone, ob eigentlich auch HSUPA unterstützt wird.
Nee, haben sie nicht. Hast du schon geschaut?
Ja, war so, dass sie das hatten, sie hatten das nicht mit dabei. Also ich hab halt vor Monaten schon die Specs von diesem neuen Chip gelesen, der S-Gold 3 heißt der von Infineon, weil dieser Sibri-Unlocker-Typ, dieser Italiener hat das ja schon in der Firmware irgendwie da rausgefunden und viele andere auch. Und da kann man sich halt die Specs von dem S-Gold 3 Chip angucken. Und da war kein HSUPA mit dabei.
Das ist aber blöd. Na, wenn du Fotos machst und du willst die hochladen, dann liest du die einfach mal mit UMTS Upload Speed. Das ist so viel nicht.
Wie viel ist es denn?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wir haben, da muss ich echt gleich nochmal nachschauen, was eigentlich der Default-Upload ist. Vieles ist das auf jeden Fall nicht. UMTS, wir befragen die allwissenden Müllhalde. Sind ja auch...
Nicht allwissend.
Nee, wir sind ja auch nicht besser als die anderen.
Aber wie mein Meister früher schon gesagt hat zu mir, und das habe ich schon sehr oft zitiert oder rezitiert, man muss nicht alles wissen, man muss nur wissen, wo es steht.
Das ist richtig. Aber auch die Wikipedia redet hier erstmal von einer Transfer-Width ab 384 Kilowatt als gäbe es irgendwie nur in die andere Richtung.
So, was sind noch die Punkte, die sie als neu vorgestellt haben?
Keine Ahnung, es ist langsam.
Die Enterprise Services halt, ganze Exchange, Deport und so weiter und den VPN Kram mit Cisco. Dann, was war noch?
Na halt alles, was bei iPhone 2.0 Software dabei ist.
Genau, das hatten wir ja schon beredet.
Genau.
Dann halt, dass es GPS kann, das haben wir jetzt auch schon beredet. Das war ja bis dahin auch noch nicht klar, in der Kino zumindest nicht. Wir benutzen wohl einen Chip von Broadcom, die vorher noch gar keinen GPS-Chip hatten, also das ist wohl ganz was Neues. Deswegen hat es wahrscheinlich auch keiner gewusst, dass es irgendwie GPS haben wird, weil die Standard-GPS-Firmen nichts sagen konnten, dass bei ihnen Chips bestellt wurden. So, was war dann noch neu?
Na, so viel war dann nicht neu.
Die Rückseite ist schwarz anstatt aus Metall, ist jetzt komplett Plastik.
Akkulaufzeit ist halt besser.
Akkulaufzeit, genau, das ist ein Punkt, der mich auch sehr stark interessiert, was mich am meisten interessiert, mir Neues zu holen, dass es halt 300 Stunden Standby hat. Das jetzige, ich komme auf zwei Tage, wenn ich Glück habe, drei, dann ist es leer. Und 300 Stunden, selbst wenn die Hälfte übrig bleibt, das sind fünf, sechs Tage.
Und das ist eigentlich das, was man haben will.
Das ist das, was man haben will.
Weil man telefoniert ja auch noch ein bisschen zwischendurch.
Genau. Also das wäre schon, also Akku, wie sie das hinbekommen haben, wo sie früher erzählt haben, 3G oder OMT ist jetzt nicht drin, weil die Akkus irgendwie nicht so lange halten.
Ja, mit 3G ist ja auch nur die Hälfte.
Ja, also das ist nur, wenn man 2G macht. Wobei ich mich wundere, was ich irgendwie, ich meine, wenn ich im Standby bin, dann kann man auf zwei, also ich verstehe nicht, wie das irgendwie laufen soll, was man da irgendwie ein- und ausschalten muss. Wenn es im Standby ist, dann macht es doch eh nichts. Und ich denke mal, wenn 2G nichts macht und 3G nichts macht, das beides sollte am Ende nichts sein.
Nein, ein Telefon macht nie nichts. Ein Telefon muss die ganze Zeit mit dem Netz reden.
Das kann man nicht vorstellen, dass ein Telefon, wenn es irgendwie 3G macht, im Standby mehr verbraucht als ein 2G. Was ist denn das?
Warum die UMTS-Steine da noch nicht, das ist mir auch nicht so ganz klar.
Also das finde ich ein bisschen komisch. Und natürlich will ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit Strom sparen sein und natürlich will ich dann, wenn ich die Datenrate benutze, dass es dann hochschaltet.
Es ist halt ein anderes Protokoll. Da umstellen müssen einfach die Telefone, um diese höheren Übertragungszahlen auch zu erreichen, einfach mehr mit dem Netz handshake. Und es geht einfach auch ein bisschen davon aus, dass man so, dass das Telefon mehr mitredet oder mithört zumindest, um dann eben auch bessere Timeslot-Nutzung zu erzielen. Weil mal ehrlich, 7,2 Megabit über ein Telefon, das hätte ich vor ein paar Jahren ja noch nicht mal für möglich gehalten.
Viele Leute haben das noch nicht mal zu Hause per DSL, die haben noch 6M mit. Wobei man dazusagen muss, das ist schon ein Unterschied, weil bei DSL hat man irgendwie 20-30 Millisekunden Latenz, bei UMTS hat man schon noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist richtig, aber am Ende zählt der Download. Ja, Latenz ist wichtig, aber nur, wenn du so Network Games machst. Also ich glaube so für Network Games taugt das nicht so, aber über WLAN sieht das schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Aber ich hatte auch vor zwei Jahren einen, meinen Guilden-Leader oder besser sagt der Raid-Leader in World of Warcraft, der hat immer über sein UMTS-Phone irgendwie World of Warcraft gespielt. Der war immer so ein bisschen hinterher von der Latenz halt, weil das braucht man halt beim Zocken, aber der konnte da locker mit zocken, hat ihn aber auch immer richtig Geld gekostet.
Tja, Geld.
Allerdings Geld, da sind wir auch gleich wieder.
Aber man fällt noch ein Hardware-Feature ein, was so nicht so häufig besprochen würde bisher. Das neue Netzteil von dem iPhone ist aber geil.
Noch kleiner geworden.
Aber so richtig klein.
Ich hab's schon gesehen auf dem Bild halt, aber noch nicht so in ganz echt, aber das alte war auch schon ganz schön klein.
Das ist eigentlich nur noch so ein Stecker, der in eine Steckdose steckt.
Mit einem USB-Ausgang.
Mit einem USB-Ausgang. Mit so ein bisschen Plastik noch dazwischen. Aber nicht mehr so dieser Klotz, den man normalerweise so erwarten würde. Es gab ja auch dieses USB-Teil für den iPod. Das war auch so ein kleineres Netzteil, aber das hat schon noch so ein bisschen, ja, halbe Zähler Rettenschaft.
Also ich hab jetzt den ersten iPod gehabt, also mit 10 GB. So gesehen war es der zweite. Das war ja mit so einem Netzteil oder Fire war er noch. Der war schon relativ klein, also kleiner als von einem Laptop. Und ich habe alle Evolutionen durch und vom letzten iPhone ist er schon ziemlich klein und dann vom neuen ist es halt noch mal kleiner. Wer weiß, wo das endet. Wobei ich mir auch gut vorstellen könnte, dass wir demnächst mal wieder anfangen, das iPhone ohne Netzteil zu verkaufen, so wie es beim iPod auch gemacht haben.
Na, ist glaube ich nicht üblich. Telefon ohne. Aber immerhin, man kann es bei USB laden, das finde ich cool. Jetzt sind wir halt beim Preis. Angeblich ist es ja billiger geworden. Das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt auch überhaupt nicht, ja. Wobei der Preis auch schon fast egal ist, weil ich zum Beispiel kriege so gesehen keins mehr, weil ich will nicht eine Providerbindung haben und es gibt das Telefon nicht mehr ohne Providerbindung. Also ohne Vertrag. Auch in Amerika nicht mehr.
Aber es wird Pre-Paid geben. Wo denn? In England und in Spanien habe ich davon gehört, dass Pre-Paid-Tarif angebildet wird.
Da muss man mal gucken. Ich weiß nur, dass sie in Amerika die Policy so geändert haben, da ist auch die interne Policy für AT&T Shops ist irgendwie irgendwo gepostet worden, dass sie dürfen das Telefon nicht mehr ohne Vertrag rausrücken. Also es ist nicht mehr so wie vorher, dass man es irgendwie einfach kaufen kann. Man nimmt es mit nach Hause und meldet es dann über iTunes an. Das fällt alles weg über diese iTunes-Anmeldung, sondern muss es direkt im Laden irgendwie anmelden.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher.
So stand es da.
Ja, aber das habe ich heute Morgen irgendwo ausgegraben. Es gibt so eine, wenn du nach 30 Tagen noch nicht aktiviert hast, dann heulen wir dir auf die Füße-Regelung, was dagegen sprechen würde.
Ja, da stand auch da, dass diese Zeit von 14 auf 30 Tage erhöht wurde.
Genau, aber das heißt ja, dass du dann immer noch etwas tun musst. Das heißt, diese Activation geht wahrscheinlich nach wie vor über iTunes, nur dass sie dich zwingen, einen Vertrag zu unterschreiben, dass du sozusagen als Vertragspartner schon mal irgendwie vorgemerkt bist und dann machst du nur noch das Handling über iTunes, keine Ahnung.
Der Graumarkt wird auf jeden Fall ordentlich einbrechen, außer dem fällt da irgendwie was ein, wie sie an iPhones rankommen.
Tja, sie sagen halt jetzt, wir haben halt 70 Länder, in denen wir das jetzt anbieten.
Brauchen wir keinen.
Aber das machen die Chinesen, ne?
Ja, und die Russen.
Aber Steve Jobs meinte in einem Interview, dass sie da, later this year, noch irgendwie Erfolge erzählen würden.
Ja, aber hier in Deutschland gibt es ja schon. Ich will aber nicht irgendwie bei der Telekom so einen dicken Vertrag haben. Was ist das?
Na ja, das iPhone bei unserem lokalen Spion-Unternehmen. Ich meine Telekom.
Achso.
Nicht wahr? Redet auch schon wieder kein Mensch drüber, ne?
Guck mal, jedenfalls der neue Preis sagt Stevie ist 199 Dollar maximal, außer für die größere 16 Gigabyte Version, die kostet dann irgendwie 299 Dollar und gibt es dann auch in weiß. Jetzt haben sie es mit den Farben komischerweise umgedreht, ich weiß nicht wieso, weil früher war das MacBook immer das schwarze teurer als das weiße, weil alle wollten schwarzes haben, mussten dadurch das teurere kaufen. Beim iPhone haben sie es jetzt anders gemacht. Die kleine Version gibt es nur in schwarz 8 Gigabyte und die große gibt es auch in weiß.
Das ist komisch, ne?
Mit so einem weißen Telefon?
Nee, aber ich glaube, Frauen wollen das haben.
Oder? Kann das sein? Na, die werden sich schon was dabei gedacht haben. Jedenfalls, das kleine gibt es nicht in weiß. So, und aber weltweit der Preis, 199 Dollar, dadurch...
Maximal heißt es.
Maximal, genau.
Was auch immer das heißen mag. Das würde ja, wenn man jetzt mal den Eurokurs...
Das geht deswegen, weil die graue Importe oder die ohne Vertrag fällt jetzt weg.
Ja gut, aber das dürfte bedeuten, dass das Telefon hier nicht mehr als 130 Euro kosten darf.
Ja, die können es dann auch schon ein bisschen anpassen, weil wir andere Garantiebestimmungen haben als in Amerika. Das war einmal zumindest der Grund, warum sie sagen, dass die Preise hier nicht...
Und Mehrwertsteuer.
Zum Beispiel. Und lass es 170 sein oder so, von mir aus auch 200. Würde ich mir ja sofort eins shoppen. Aber du kriegst es ja nicht ohne Vertrag. Und bei AT&T ist der Vertrag um 10 Dollar teurer geworden.
Und du musst wahrscheinlich auch noch mal ganze zwei Jahre unterschreiben.
Ja, genau. Wobei ich wohl gehört habe, dass in Amerika, wenn du in den Laden gehst und du hast schon ein altes iPhone, kannst du sagen, okay, ab jetzt mein Vertrag wieder auf zwei Jahre und dann kriegst du gleich ein neues iPhone in die Hand gedrückt.
Aber du musst ein altes zurückgeben. Na ja, das könnte man sicherlich auch noch gewinnbringend verkaufen, weil da wird jetzt eine extreme Nachfrage aufkommen.
Weil keiner das Neue kriegt, wollen alle noch mal schnell ein altes sich besorgen, das kann sein. Aber was passiert zum Beispiel, wenn jemand jetzt ein neues iPhone hat und es wurde ihm geklaut, muss man ja nicht mal sagen, sondern es wurde wirklich geklaut, muss er doch in Laden gehen können, muss dann können, ich habe euren Vertrag schon, jetzt gib mir mal so ein neues Telefon. Kostet das dann 199 Dollar, weil dann entsteht der Graumarkt ja sowieso wieder, weil jeder sagt, ihm wurde sein Telefon geklaut.
Das Problem gab es schon, als das 16 Gigabyte iPhone rauskam und die Telekom am Anfang auch irgendwie meinte, wenn du 16 Gigabyte haben willst, dann musst du noch mal zwei Jahre abschließen, aber das haben sie dann wohl auch geändert, weil das auch irgendwie gar nicht geht. Aber ich muss auch sagen, für mich ist das auch noch ein echtes Problem, also eigentlich technisch ist mit dem Teil jetzt alles in Ordnung, also ich sehe jetzt nichts, also okay, hat keine Videokamera drauf geschissen, so also.
Ist nicht so schlimm, muss mal gucken, ob es jetzt eigentlich mal Bluetooth für den, also Netz für den Rechner machen kann.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ja, aber das ist so ein bisschen blöd. Was soll ich mit dem ganzen?
Aber es gab da einen interessanten Hack, ne?
Ja, gab's.
Ja, jemand hat einfach, und zwar einfach, dass das Teil so einen Ad-hoc-WLAN aufmacht, also so ein Computer-to-Computer-Network-Joint.
Ist halt ein Rechner.
Und dann einfach einen Hack, dass du einfach die Route umlängst, dass das IP, was da reinkommt, übers WLAN weitergeroutet wird.
Ich war letztens in einem Laden und hab eine SMS verschickt noch irgendwie, weil ich da einen Post abgegeben hab und da meinte die Dame hinter dem Tresen, ist ja ein iPhone, ist ja so ein halber Computer, meinte ich nicht, ist ein ganzer, weißt du einfach so.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt. Also ich bin mir da auch so ein bisschen unschlüssig. Technisch ist das Teil einfach in Ordnung und vom Preis her, naja, also der Tarif ist teurer. Also es gibt jetzt keine iPhone-Tarife mehr.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja, also eigentlich sind sie eingebrochen, ja, also so ihres andere Shopping Experience, du kaufst irgendwo, nimmst es mit nach Hause oder iTunes, ja, die haben einfach eingesehen, oh Gott, jetzt gehen hier alle Telefone, gehen nach China, so, was weiß ich, wie viel Prozent aller Telefone am Ende wirklich gehackt waren. Echt viele wahrscheinlich.
Ja, die Hälfte bestimmt.
Und da haben sie irgendwie Stress bekommen mit ihren Providen mit diesem harten Deal und ich glaube, die haben ganz schön eines auf die Mütze bekommen, insbesondere in Europa, wo einfach ihre Rechnung nicht aufgegangen ist. Also mit der Telekom 100.000 Telefone haben sie verkauft, ich meine, Hallo, 100.000 Telefone, ist ja wohl nicht viel. Na ja, ist nicht wenig, aber ist auch nicht gerade bahnbrechend. Also ich hatte nicht so den Eindruck, dass jetzt hier so eine besondere Euphorie entstanden ist, dadurch, dass die Telekom das iPhone anbietet.
Also ich dachte, dass sie es eigentlich jetzt freisetzen, das Telefon, weil sie ihren Appstore haben und da drüber verdienen wollen und denen das sozusagen egal ist, weil da drüber die Kohle reinkommt. Aber es scheint nicht so zu sein. Die wollen wirklich beides abgreifen.
Ja, aber angeblich nehmen sie jetzt halt nicht mehr, verdienen sie nicht mehr an diesem Tarif mit. Das heißt, es gibt dadurch auch keinen speziellen iPhone-Tarif mehr.
Aber es kann eigentlich nicht sein, sie rückt das Telefon billiger raus, also Apple rückt es billiger raus.
Ja, aber die Provider zahlen einen höheren Preis. Die Provider berechnen mehr Geld für den Tarif, bei AT&T sind es 10 Dollar mehr.
Zahlen aber an Apple mehr als 190 Dollar.
Bei zwei Jahren Laufzeit zahlst du 140 Dollar mehr für das neue iPhone als für das alte. Das heißt, faktisch ist es teurer geworden.
Wo landet die Kohle?
Die landet bei AT&T, die aber dieses Telefon subventionieren müssen, um es überhaupt so billig zu verkaufen.
Die ist für 199 Dollar schon subventioniert.
Ich schätze mal, dass Apple mehr Geld bekommt vom Provider für das Telefon als vorher. Vorher haben sie mehr vom Kunden genommen, jetzt nehmen sie es mehr vom Provider. Und der Provider ist auch noch gezwungen, es für maximal 199 Dollar zu verkaufen. Sie können es auch billiger verkaufen, müssen das aber auch alles noch subventionieren. Also sie haben es irgendwie gedreht. Sie haben sich trennen müssen, von dem wir verdienen am Telefonieren mit. Aber dafür mussten sie andere Konzessionen machen, sind aber irgendwie immer noch relativ hart an den Providern dran.
Also die 200 Dollar sind schon subventioniert, wahrscheinlich zahlt AT&T 4 oder 500 Dollar an Apple. Wahrscheinlich ganz so viel, weil die rechnen immer ein bisschen anders, aber eine höhere Summe auf jeden Fall, weil irgendwie muss Apple ja die Kohle wieder reinkriegen.
Zu viel wird es nicht sein.
Aber wenn sie vorher für die zwei Jahre 10 Dollar pro Monat bekommen haben, das sind auch 240 Dollar für die zwei Jahre.
Keiner weiß genau, wie es ist. Ich denke, das ist irgendwie so ein ganz uriger Mix. Letztendlich zählt ja nur, was kommt für die Kunden bei raus. Und de facto kostet das iPhone jetzt mehr als vorher. Aber alle schreien und jubeln, wie billig es doch jetzt ist.
Ich nicht.
Ja, wir machen das hier nicht. Nicht bei Mobile Max. So einfach kriegt ihr uns nicht.
Aber die Kriminalitätsrate wird steigen, weil ich muss jetzt einen überfallen, um so ein iPhone zu kriegen.
Oh je, das ist so wie mit Fingerabdruckbiometrie für Autos. Muss dann mit gleich den ganzen Finger absteigen.
Das ist ja mal kacke. Okay, also keinen Überfall.
Das ist schon recht safe irgendwie, ne?
Ja, und da sind die halt so ein bisschen evil.
Gibt es denn jetzt wenigstens einen, mein Telefon wurde geklaut, Service? Das wäre doch mal was Cooles.
Es gibt ja Remote Vibe für die Exchange.
Ich bin nicht Remote Vibe, sondern ich will Remote...
Explode.
Ja, ein Remote Explode, das wäre doch mal was. Nicht mehr ein Remote Explode, sondern ein Remote Explode, der den Dieb sozusagen gleich mit in die ewigen Jagdgründe befindet. Das haben wir jetzt nicht gesagt.
Aber es war wirklich so.
Was?
Die haben da so gesuchten Terroristen irgendwie ihm ein Handy zukommen lassen, wie auch immer, und das ist dann allzeit telefoniert, er explodiert.
Ist das eine belegte Geschichte?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Du glaubst schon, dass es eine belegte Geschichte ist?
Na doch, es ist.
Was heißt belegt?
Wenn ich jetzt die Fakten nicht direkt auf meinem Screen habe, kann ich das natürlich nicht sagen, weil mein Gehirn ist natürlich auch manipulierbar.
Es braucht nicht viel Kreativität, um sich sowas auszumalen. Wie auch immer. Bleiben wir noch mal beim Thema. Man kann gar nicht so viel sagen zu diesen Telefonen. Ist das irgendwie okay?
Ich bin voll überzeugt. Und als die Keynote noch lief, dachte ich, das ist es, wie kriege ich es? 200 Dollar je Jahr?
Und dann der Downer?
Und dann der Downer? Das gibt es halt nicht mehr ohne Vertrag. Jetzt muss man mal gucken, wie man da so rankommt.
Das gab es auch vorher in dem Sinne nicht wirklich ohne Vertrag.
Das ist richtig, aber da ging es halt. Das stimmt schon. Aber was ich gerne hätte jetzt, damit Apple nicht evil ist, ist, dass sie oder die Telekom oder wer auch immer bei uns hier, dass es irgendwie im Angebot gibt, dann halt für 300 Euro ohne Vertrag oder so. Damit könnte ich ja leben. Oder zumindest, vielleicht könnte ich damit nicht leben. Aber dann würde ich sagen, okay, ist mir halt zu teuer, dann lasse ich es halt. Aber es wäre halt eine Möglichkeit. Aber so geht es ja gar nicht. Ja, da war es aber 750 Euro ohne Vertrag, weil 750 ist ein bisschen sehr viel für doch relativ kleinen Computer. So 400 vielleicht, ist aber auch schon ganz schön viel.
Es ist, ich weiß auch nicht, was das soll.
Oder man rechnet sich das durch, denkt, okay, wenn es hier 200 Euro kostet, ob ich nun 400 Euro oder 200 Euro bezahle, dann zahle ich 200 Euro und investiere die anderen 200 Euro in den teureren Vertrag, den man dann mit der Telekom schlucken würde.
Wenn es wenigstens Competition geben würde, also in Österreich zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt zwei Anbieter.
Ja, aber ich habe mal geguckt, die haben bei Apple so eine schicke Seite mit den ganzen Fähnchen. Bei Apple natürlich sind die Fähnchen alle rund, so wie Bubbles. Wo ist denn die Seite? Na, bei iPhone und dann irgendwie Countries oder so, musst du mal gucken. apple.com/iphoneunddann sind die ganzen Länder aufgelistet, also die aktuellen und die demnächst kommen werden. Und für die Schweiz ist es so, dass der eine Anbieter macht die französische Schweiz und der andere macht irgendwie die deutsche Schweiz. Und für Österreich, was, Österreich? Aber Österreich ist doch vom Land gar nicht geteilt. Nein, Belgien war es, Belgien war es, glaube ich. Das ist auch nochmal so zweigeteilt, weil die sind ja auch mehr Sprachen. Da waren die Provider mal pro Sprache da irgendwie unterschiedlich.
Ach echt? Achso, du meinst irgendwie in Kanada, französisch gibt es einen anderen Provider? Nee, die machen doch alles mit Rogers.
Aber es war auf jeden Fall in Frankreich so, dass da in Klammern extra nochmal die Sprache dahinter stand.
Ja, aber das machen sie deshalb, weil die Seite, auf die du dann kommst, auch in der entsprechenden Sprache ist. Das hat nichts mit dem Provider zu tun.
Das könnte allerdings sein.
Das ist alles so. Und wo ist hier Austria? Klicken wir nochmal, irgendwie 11. Juli gibt es auch Österreich. Da ist ein iPhone auf, das sie gewartet haben. In einem schnellen 3G-Gerät. Ich sehe ein 3G. Weitere Infos. Wer hat das eigentlich erfunden? Infos ist so ein Scheißwort. So, und was soll man da jetzt sehen deiner Meinung nach? Wer es anbietet?
Hast du die Lander-Kügelchen?
Ich hatte die Lander-Kügelchen schon, aber ich bekomme nicht zu dir.
Jetzt kommen wir hoch, ein bisschen höher. Du weißt doch, die Schweizer fahren jetzt irgendwo zweimal höher, höher, höher. Hier, da und da, siehst du?
Ja, das habe ich schon gesehen. Aber das bringt mich jetzt nicht weiter, weil da steht immer noch nicht, wer das Ding verkauft.
Ja, aber es waren die Länder, die diese Doppelangebote hatten. Aber hast recht, vielleicht ist es dort wirklich nur wegen der Sprache.
Nee, in der Schweiz gibt es nur einen Provider. So, welche gibt es denn da?
Da gab es noch diese riesenlange Liste von Apple.
Also apple.com/pr. Das ist eigentlich die Webseite, die ist nicht so gut verlinkt. Aber da sind immer die ganzen Pressreleases. Das ist manchmal, wenn man wirklich wissen will, was passiert ist, die einzige Möglichkeit, einen klaren Kopf zu kriegen. Und hier gibt es das erste Mal, sehe ich das bei Apple, also ein Disclosure Triangle bei Pressreleases, wo du dann alle Pressreleases aufklappen kannst. Austria, also T-Mobile macht Austria und Orange. Also Orange bietet das iPhone in Frankreich an Portugal, Schweiz und Österreich. Und T-Mobile in Österreich, Deutschland und Niederlande. So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, Switzerland sind die noch mal.
Switzerland ist Swisscom.
Auch Swisscom und Orange. Okay, hast recht. Gut, so, und jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie wirkt sich das da auf die Tarife auf? Weil Auswahl im Prinzip gibt es hier mal, naja, also Competition ist vielleicht noch nicht das richtige Wort, aber es gibt zumindest zwei Anbieter, die natürlich dann schon irgendeinen Incentive bieten müssen, dass die Leute zu ihnen kommen. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie jetzt wirklich absolut den identischen Tarif anbieten. Sie sagen ja auch alle noch nichts über Preise. Also die einzigen Preise, die jetzt wirklich verfügbar sind, sind meines Wissens O2 in England und halt in USA. Und da ist es nur LTE und Tim.
Von der Telekom gibt es auch noch keine Preise, ne? Dann können wir da nicht berichten, weil das ist das, was unsere Hörer hier interessiert, was das iPhone denn mit Vertrag hier kosten würde.
Tja, das werden wir alles noch erfahren. Wir müssen uns auf die Technik stürzen. Ich glaube, das hat jetzt gar keinen Sinn, hier groß in irgendwelchen Preisen rum zu rätseln und rum zu vorwerken. Das wird eine lange Sendung heute, ist dir schon klar, ne?
Damit werden wir mit dem iPhone jetzt erstmal durch, glaube ich.
Ich denke auch, sehr viel mehr kann man dazu nicht sagen.
Langsam geht es mir echt auf den Sack.
Oh, mein Telefon klingelt.
Wo ist mein Telefon?
Das iPhone?
Okay.
Boah, weißt du, dass es dann klingelt? Ja, war nur ein Spaß. Ich frage mich, ob das mit dem Schneeleoparden auch nur ein Spaß war.
Der wurde ja in der Keynote nur mit einem Wort erwähnt, dass der Mertrand Serrelet, oder wie heißt der, Franz Susselle, dass der nach der Keynote das dann halt vorstellen wird, den Snow Leopard und mehr ist über Mac OS X auf der Keynote nichts gefallen an Wort. Die Fahnenstellung kam aber nur noch gleich danach und die stand dann eigentlich auch schon unter NDA, aber da wurde ergiebig drüber berichtet und Apple war auch so genehmigt, um auch da ein Presse-Release oder ein Presse-Dings hier Mitteilungen rauszugeben.
Was? Presse-Release für Schneeleopard?
Ja, da standen noch mal so ein paar Sachen da.
Ah, doch da. Nee, ich hab nur die Seiten gelesen. Also sie haben ja auch noch zwei Seiten einmal zu teilen und zur Server-Geschichte. Da guck ich jetzt noch mal kurz durch, ob da noch irgendwas anderes drinsteht, aber das war ich stark zu bezweifeln. Ja, also sie sagen halt, dass es irgendwie keine Features hat.
Ja, da kann ich gleich mal was zu sagen, was ich mir da so zu denke. Und zwar ist es so, und es ist auch jetzt wohl schon offiziell, dass das Snow Leopard nicht für PowerPC rauskommt.
Was macht dich da so sicher?
Es gibt einen Screenshot von dem Staller, wo als Bedingung steht, dass man einen Intel-Rechner dafür braucht.
Aber das kann natürlich die aktuelle Version sein.
Dass sie die dann noch mal ändern? Unwahrscheinlich. Und es macht auch Sinn, dass sie den alten Schrott rausschmeißen, weil in einem Jahr ist wieder, also noch ein Jahr vergangen, wo man halt auf PowerPC zurückgeht. Also jetzt ist es vielleicht noch eine harte Entscheidung, weil es ist erst zwei, drei Jahre her oder so, zweieinhalb, in einem Jahr ist aber schon wieder eins dazugekommen und dann wird es nicht mehr so viele PowerPC-Rechner geben. Ich finde, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Zumal es ja auch keine neuen Features hat, in Anführungsstrichen.
Genau, ich glaube, das ist halt nur so ein Hack, den ich jetzt leider verrate, tut mir leid für euch, aber so ist es. Sie sagen natürlich, dass es keine neue Feature hat, damit es den PowerPC-Leuten nicht so weh tut. So wie das Kind halt unbedingt eishammeln und die Mama sagt, es geht ja gar nicht, weil die Läden haben ja schon zu.
Ich würde das anders sagen. Sie sagen keine Features, weil nicht so viele visible Features da sein werden. Es ist nicht so was wie Time Machine mit eigenem User-Interface. Es ist nichts, was der User als Feature wahrnimmt tatsächlich.
Und sie werden sich auch bemühen, das ein bisschen flach zu halten. Wie gesagt, sonst wäre das Geschrei halt groß. Aber es ist natürlich prima jetzt zu sagen, keine Features, weil es passt auch so in dieses Marketing rein. Weil, wisst ihr, da sieht man einfach, es ist mal gefloppt, weil es auch, ich weiß gar nicht, woran eigentlich, aber auch, die haben einfach zu lange gebraucht und alles ist bunt und toll und schick und so weiter. Das wollte Apple jetzt nicht machen. Die Leute, also gerade auch die Windows-User, die wechseln, die wollen was Vernünftiges, was Stabiles und was Sicheres. Und wenn Apple sagt, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Apple sicher ist, dann kommen wieder gleich ganz viele Leute und sagen, es ist ja nicht so. Aber sie sagen zumindest, sie bemühen sich jetzt mal, der Stabilität reinzubringen und irgendwie es sicherer zu machen und irgendwie die Feature mal so ein bisschen hinten anzustellen. Aber ich glaube, es ist auch nur so ein Marketing-Dings. Weil unten drunter passiert da eine ganze Menge. Und wenn dein Rechner abstürzt und nicht mehr stabil ist, dann ist es deswegen, weil es unten drunter nicht stimmt, nicht weil die Features oben nicht stimmen. Deswegen stürzt mein Rechner nicht ab.
So sehe ich das auch.
Da tut sich halt eine Menge. Und mich interessiert halt dieses Grand Central. Da kann ich ja noch was zu erzählen. Vielleicht findet ein User da noch was raus. Und zwar ist Grand Central so eine Sache als...
Ein Hörer meinst du?
User? Hab ich User gesagt?
Ja, du hast User gesagt.
Unser Hörer sind ja auch User, hoffe ich.
Und meinst du, wir sind ein Betriebssystem?
Ich bin... Wie ist es? Der Master Process? Nee.
Du bist der Podcast.
Ja, nein. Da gibt es ein Framework, das heißt Grand Central. Das soll in Snow Leopard halt kommen. Was für...
Multi-Core-Optimization ist.
Multi-Core-Optimization ist und die Events ein bisschen steuert und weiß, wie der Rechner gerade ausgelastet ist, wie viele Cores oder CPUs gerade irgendwie der Rechner hat. Weil es können ja auch mal mehr und weniger werden. Und vielleicht, also bei Sun geht sowas, da kann man CPUs abmelden und wieder anmelden. Und, obwohl, Mac geht es auch mit so einer speziellen Developer Software, aber ist jetzt egal. Jedenfalls, dieses Software, dieses Framework, da soll wohl, habe ich gelesen, ich finde es nur nicht mehr, soll Objective-C eine Spracherweiterung kriegen. Und zwar, dass man in Objective-C Blöcke deklarieren kann, die threadmäßig einzeln abgearbeitet werden können, sodass dieses Grand Central Framework sieht alles klar. Da ist so ein Block, den kann ich irgendwie der CPU zuweisen und den nächsten Block irgendwie einer anderen CPU, also dass die unabhängig voneinander sind. Ich finde es nur nicht mehr wieder. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendeiner, der in einer WWDC, in einer Keynote saß, da Müll zusammengeschrieben hat, was ich irgendwie abgelesen habe und was vielleicht danach verschwunden ist, weil es nicht stimmt. Oder dass es irgendwie so ein bisschen untergegangen ist. Aber das schreibt man ja auch nicht einfach so, dass Objective-C eine Spracherweiterung kriegt. Das wäre ja schon was größeres. Das ist auf jeden Fall noch für mich eine spannende Geschichte.
Ja, das stimmt. Also ich meine, da muss man jetzt eigentlich auch nicht so groß rätseln. Hörne, wenn Sie jetzt wirklich... Also man muss glaube ich zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Einerseits ist dieses Parallelcomputing explizit unterstützen. Ich meine, da gibt es halt verschiedene... Es gibt ja diese Flinz Taxonomy. Also es gibt so verschiedene Arten und Weisen, wie man halt Parallelisierung machen kann. So Single Instruction, Single Data, Single Instruction, Multiple Data, SIMD Erweiterung haben wir ja im Prinzip auch schon im Prozessor mit drin, mit SSE und früher beim PowerPC schon mit AltiVec und solche Sachen. Da war ja im Prinzip auch schon solche Parallelisierung mit vorgegeben. Jetzt geht es irgendwie hin zu Multiple Instruction, Multiple Data, dass du halt große Datenmengen hast und verschiedene Instruktionen, die du dann mit diesen Daten machen kannst, also riesige Listen. Und da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass vor allem diese andere Sache, die sie angekündigt haben, dieses OpenCL, eine große Rolle mitspielt. Also es hängt wahrscheinlich alles irgendwie zusammen.
Aber das OpenCL haben sie am Anfang ein bisschen durcheinander gebracht. Das OpenCL ist ja...
Für Grafikkarten. Genau, für GPUs.
Die aber auch halt den Jobs der CPU übernehmen. Also es hat dann nichts mehr mit Grafik zu tun, sondern die Grafikkarten sollen halt...
Ja, aber Grafikkarten sind stark in Parallelisierung.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht, dass die Leute denken, irgendwie ihr 3D-Shooter wird schneller, darum geht's nicht. Sondern dass die Grafikkarte Jobs macht, die halt Berechnungen ausführt oder den Film darstellt.
Genau, Schlüssel knackt, was auch immer. Also so 3D-Programme könnten das nutzen. Und das macht natürlich schwer Sinn. Und dieses OpenCL ist eine Abstraktion, dass man das eben ausführen kann. Und wenn halt eine GPU da ist, dann weiß das OS, wie es das dieser GPU zu vermitteln hat. Und dann läuft das da ab und man muss nicht für eine spezielle GPU machen.
Und wenn die GPU das nicht kann, dass es dann halt trotzdem die CPU macht.
Und ich vermute mal, dass sie mit NVIDIA zusammenarbeiten. Bei dieser Sache.
Weil sie schlau sind und sie sind schlau, arbeiten sie wie immer mit beiden zusammen.
Ja, bei NVIDIA hat ja mit einem System, das nennt sich CUDA, C-U-D-A, Compute Unified Device Architecture, im Prinzip genau sowas gemacht.
Das ist eine C. Aber Arti hat doch auch sowas.
Das kann gut sein, da weiß ich jetzt aber nicht, wie es heißt.
Weil die werden ja doof sein, wenn sie nur auf einen gehen, weil die müssen auch immer zwei gegeneinander ausboten. Das machen sie doch schon seit Jahren.
Ja klar, deswegen machen sie das ja. Sie machen da von vornherein eine Abstraktion. Sie haben wahrscheinlich gesehen, NVIDIA prescht voran mit diesem CUDA, die waren ja schon immer so ein bisschen schneller. Sie sehen halt, okay, das macht einfach mal schwer Sinn, zumal sie ja das auch schon nutzen. In ihren ganzen Core-Video, Core-Animation und so weiter, die ganzen Frameworks, Quads benutzt einfach auch schon diese Ressourcen. Und auch ihr OpenGL-Treiber wurde ja vor einiger Zeit im Speed beschleunigt, weil sie halt einen höheren Grad an Parallelisierung mit reingebracht haben. Und ich denke, da greift sie einfach eine ganze Menge Sachen mit rein. Da greift rein dieser LLVM-Compiler, wo sie sicher den Developer von LLVM schon vor ein, zwei Jahren als Angestellten geholt haben.
Chris Plattner oder so wie er hieß.
Genau, das macht eh viel Sinn für ihr Objective-See, es macht generell auch Sinn für ihre Treiber und ihre sonstigen Architekturen. Das spielt sicherlich auch in dieses OpenCL mit rein. Und jetzt kommen halt auch noch diese Sachen mit, wir müssen Parallelisierung machen. Parallelisierung einerseits, diese Hardcore-Ausführen von Code, der halt Massive, wie soll ich das nennen? Also so Rendering und sowas, da hast du einfach viel gleichförmige Daten und dann eben gleichförmige Instruktionen und das muss dann einfach so schnell wie möglich laufen. Das kann man in die Grafikrate schmeißen. Aber das andere Problem ist, jetzt kommen wir wieder ein bisschen an den Anfang der Diskussion, ist auch das Nutzen von verschiedenen Prozessor-Cores. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass sie sowas nicht schon drin haben. Sie haben ja schon auf der letzten WWDC auch Methoden vorgestellt, Frameworks, wie du eben dem Betriebssystem so bestimmte Chunks geben kannst, wie dein Program-Flow sich automatisieren lässt. Und ich denke, das bringen sie jetzt auch einfach auf einen neuen Level und geben dem ganzen noch einen Namen, eben dieses Grand Central, sozusagen ihr Verschiebebahnhof, wo du dann dein Programm in verschiedene Güterwaggons aufteilen kannst und das Betriebssystem setzt es für dich dann irgendwie ins Rätsel, also in die Züge zusammen und dann fährt das irgendwie mehr Gleise. Ich denke mal, das ist so die Assoziation, die sie an der Stelle auch irgendwie haben wollen. Und ich finde das cool, weil wenn Ihnen das gelingt, mehr aus den Chores rauszuholen und vor allem durch diese Atempause, wo sie sagen, okay, wir werfen jetzt mal keine Programmierer auf großen High-Level-Kram, sondern da wird eigentlich nur debugged, stabilisiert, Performance gemacht und diese Frameworks gleich mit eingebaut, weil das wäre dann sozusagen konsequent. Auf der einen Seite haben sie ihr Grand Central, weil das ist wahrscheinlich schon weitgehend fertig und jetzt beschäftigen sie sich im Wesentlichen damit, wie sie den oberen Teil ihres Betriebssystems, also ihre eigenen Anwendungen, aber natürlich auch die Frameworks selber, das nutzen lassen können, sodass auf so einem Multi-Quartal...
Das hat auch dieser Bertrand Salé schon gesagt, sie haben die letzten sieben Jahre oder was 1000 Features für das OS X programmiert und dieses Snow Leopard irgendwie bereitet die Grundlage für die nächsten 1000 Features. Das passt das ja eigentlich schon gut zusammen. Aber halt, weil man muss auch alten Scheiß mal über Bord werfen, fliegt halt der PowerPC Support raus. So wie es aussieht.
Ja, ich könnte es mir vorstellen, weil letzten Endes ist es so, die G4 Powerbooks, also G4 ist wahrscheinlich schon eine Technologie, die man fallen lassen will und G5 gab es dann eigentlich nur die Mac Pros.
Genau, die haben ja Leopard, so ist es ja nicht. Also es ist jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Aber es war noch nicht so viele. Also G5 war zwar schnell, aber es war nicht so viele.
Und Leute, die den Nutzen von so einem Snow Leopard ziehen wollen, also das ist so mit vielen, vielen Cores richtig schnelles.
Die haben eh schon ein 8-Core Mac Pro.
So sieht es aus. Da kommst du mit so einem G5 auch nicht mehr mit. Vor allem hat der ja nur vier CPUs. Ist ja nicht mehr so viel heute. Wird vielleicht in einem Jahr schon ein Laptop sein, wer weiß.
Aber es gibt dann doch noch ein paar coole Features. Auch wenn sie sagen, es gibt keine Features, also eine Sache ist drin, wo ich die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen habe und gesagt, endlich. QuickTime X.
Man kann sich noch gar nichts darüber vorstellen, aber alle freuen sich schon.
Alle freuen sich.
Da kann man schon sehen, wie scheiße alle die aktuelle QuickTime Implementation finden.
Es ist so zum Kotzen. Vor ein paar Tagen hab ich wieder so ein Ding gehabt, wieder so ein richtiger QuickTime-Snort. Und zwar hab ich alte Filme, die wir mal im Kontext mit Blink-Lights generiert haben, das waren so Preview-Animationen, die haben so Codex benutzt wie den PNG-Codex. Dann hast du so eine Maske und dann werden halt irgendwie so die blinke Fensterchen da mit eingeblendet. Und die hab ich einfach nochmal abgespielt, also unveränderte Dateien, die einfach seit mehreren Jahren so auf meiner Platte liegen. Und was ist gecrasht? Nein, noch geiler, der QuickLook-Server. Da kommt man echt ins Grübeln, oder? Das heißt, da ist irgendwie eine Vermengung mit den QuickTime-Plugins. Weißt du, PNG, Kodec, das heißt, der nutzt da wahrscheinlich auch irgendeinen PNG.
Das gibt es ja für das Tool von Quartz. QuickLook hat ja lauter Plugins, da muss es dann auch ein QuickTime-Plugin geben.
Keine Ahnung, also auf jeden Fall ist das alles irgendwie rottig. Der Player ist natürlich dann auch irgendwie in die Knie gegangen und irgendwie musste gekillt werden und all dieses, bloß der Crash Report kam halt für einen QuickLook-Server dabei raus. Was mir einfach nur sagt, ist, dieses QuickTime passt da einfach nicht mehr rein. Und es ist langsam, es ist scheiße. Ich meine, guck dir an, wie lange ein iTunes braucht, um einen Film zu starten, wenn du Space drückst.
Ja, aber iTunes ist ja auch noch so eine Sache. Das hätte die Frage, ob in Snowdrapern auch Kabel...
iTunes ist noch mal so eine Sache, aber es ist auch trotzdem im QuickTime-Player schon scheiße. Auch der braucht einfach zu lange. Ich drücke auf Space und ich kann so 21, 22, 23... Das dauert einfach ewig, bis der mit diesem scheiß Film weitermacht. Guck dir an, wie so ein VLC und ein M-Player. Ich meine, das sind nun auch wirklich... Aber komm, das ist auch......Probleme, die man nicht benutzen will, aber trotzdem... Ja, aber wir sind in der Lage, schnell auch durch so ein Ding durchzuskippen. Ja, ich kann da irgendwie auf den Cursor rechts drücken und dann macht so Rats, Rats, Rats, Rats, Rats, Rats, und dann ist da mir durch 10 Minuten Film durchgeflogen und ich hab zwischendurch noch gesehen, was Sache ist. Und mach das mal bei QuickTime. Da dreckst du da mit der Maus irgendwie an diesem komischen Pfeil dran rum und so... kommt überhaupt nicht vorwärts. Vollpräge Scheiße.
Kommt aber auch auf den Codec an.
Kommt immer auf den Codec an, aber ich hab bisher noch keinen mit dem es wirklich befriedigend fix war.
Also ich hab ja hier diesen lossless Codec, wie ist der das? Scheiße, ich hab den Namen vergessen. Es gibt so einen lossless Videocodec.
Du meinst jetzt nicht den Animation-Codec, sondern diesen anderen?
Den finde ich noch raus für die Sendung. Jedenfalls der ist lossless, der ist prima für Leute, die später schneiden wollen, damit die Animationen oder was auch immer du alles so machst lossless, damit die Qualität nicht drauf geht. Und der ist lossless, aber mit Compression. Und der ist total ratzfatz, also wenn dein Film auf einer schnellen Platte liegt, und das kann locker mal so ein 20 Gigabyte Movie sein oder 30 oder so, weil die werden natürlich dementsprechend groß, die Filmchen. Wenn du da hin und her slidest, das ist instant. Also du slidest und der zieht mit, ohne Verzögerung oder alles. Weil der muss halt auch keine Keyframe suchen, weil durch lossless ist ja alles ein Keyframe. Und das geht total schnell. Das ist auch teilweise ein Problem halt von den Codex, dass halt nicht an jeder Stelle ein Keyframe ist. Wenn du da hinspielst, muss er erst das nächste Keyframe suchen und so. Und das hat dieser lossless-Codec nicht.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich sogar einen guten Grund, warum sie ein komplett neues Quick Time unbedingt benötigen. Weil sie sich entschlossen haben, Carbon 64 zu killen. Die 64-Bit-Geschichte hatten wir schon. Und 64-Bit ist einfach mal für so ein Medienframework echt wichtig.
Wird dann Carbon bei Snow Leopard noch dabei sein? Wahrscheinlich schon, aber halt 64-Bit halt nicht.
Nö, die werden jetzt nicht Carbon wegschmeißen, aber sie werden halt... Also davon habe ich jetzt noch nichts gehört. Es gab ja dieses Gerücht, dass dann sozusagen alles nur noch Coco ist. Na gut, die Frage ist, was das heißt. Für mich könnte das heißen... Also ich glaube nicht, dass es nicht mehr Carbon gibt, weil dann würden einfach zu viele Programme sterben und wahrscheinlich der ganze Adobe-Kram und so weiter. Dann könntest du einfach nicht mehr laufen lassen und würde niemand upgraden. Aber was es wahrscheinlich... Also was es vielleicht bedeuten könnte, ist, dass alle Features des Betriebssystems über einen Coco-Interface zu erreichen sind. Das wäre schon mal ein großes Ziel. Bisher war es noch so eine hybride Geschichte. Da gab es halt dieses QT-Kit, aber mit dem QT-Kit konntest du halt nicht alles machen, sondern immer nur so ein Teil. Und dann wäre es sozusagen das Ziel von Snow Leopard, dass man halt irgendwie alles in Coco anbietet. Was ja auch einfach Zeit wird. Und wahrscheinlich sind sie in dieses QuickTime X, ich vermute mal, mit diesem Media-Kit, was sie auf dem iPhone haben, viel zu tun haben.
Dieser Video-Code, der uns dieser loslässt, der heißt Sheer Video, S-H-E-E-R. Der ist so für, wenn man High-Quality-Video-Zeugs macht.
Aber auf dem iPhone haben sie ja auch schon irgendwie Media Handling, da haben sie kein vollständiges QuickTime drauf, aber auch da müssen sie irgendwie Ton und Bild anzeigen, auch wenn sich das im Wesentlichen auf das H264...
Und zwar CPU-sparend, und das ist ja wohl auch eine große Sache von dem QuickTime X, dass es halt...
Ja, und wahrscheinlich kommen dann auch noch diese OpenCL-Geschichten mit rein, dass sie dann wirklich auch die GPUs nutzen können für Berechnungen, Codex laufen dann auch mit auf der Grafikkarte, mit drauf, generisch, so ne Sachen... Ja gut, aber die Tür machen sie sich damit im Prinzip auf. Es ist ja durchaus möglich, wenn es dieses OpenCL-Framework gibt, warum sollte ein Codec das nicht benutzen? Und ein Codec hat von der Power, die eine Grafikkarte bietet, am meisten. Weil du musst das nicht ins Software machen. Guck dir an, was Flash-Video für ein Scheiß ist. Man hat drei Spiegel-Webseiten offen und dein Rechner fängt an zu blasen.
Ja, wollte ich grad sagen. Was geht der Lüfter los?
Ja, furchtbar ist das. Und das liegt halt an diesem ganzen Kram. Und Codecs müssen einfach mal in Hardware laufen, weil heutzutage, wenn man HD haben und das kriegst du einfach... Das ist einfach sinnlos, da die CPU drauf zu werfen, wenn du eine Grafikkarte hast, die eigentlich 99% die ganze Zeit vor sich hineidelt. Klar, ich meine, Quartz benutzt so ein bisschen, was das GUI und so weiter, nutzt irgendwie auch...
Aber es ist bis heute noch nicht, dieses Quartz, ich muss jetzt kurz gucken, wie es heißt, Quartz Extreme, was die eigentlich schon zur 10.4 einschalten wollten. Da gab es auch eine schicke Präsentation, aber sie haben es irgendwie nie gemacht. Auch bei 10.5 war es dann immer noch irgendwie nicht an. Und zwar... Wo ist es? Ich hab hier dieses Quartz, die Bugtool, da kann man das nämlich einschalten, wenn man den Xcode installiert hat. Und das heißt... Ja, das... Quartz GL ist immer noch nicht aktiviert.
Weil das Probleme gemacht hat?
Immer noch, seit drei, vier Jahren. Sie hatten wohl Probleme mit dem Font-Rendering. Sie wollten ja alles auf die Grafikkarte auslagern, also so komplett alles. Und das Font-Rendering war wohl schwierig, auf die Grafikkarte auszulagern. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es daran gescheitert ist, aber es gibt es bis heute nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, woran es gescheitert ist. Finde es auch schade, aber wobei ich das mitbekommen habe, gab es einfach wieder Kompatibilitätsprobleme mit Programmen. Das ist wahrscheinlich genauso wie mit dieser User Interface Resolution.
Das ist ja auch ein Grund, dass hier irgendwie die Kabel raus muss, weil vielleicht haben ja die sich einen Ärger gemacht und die müssen weg. Aber man kann es einschalten bei seinem Rechner mit diesem Quarz-Debug-Tool.
Und funktioniert dann irgendwas nicht, wenn du es eingeschaltet hast?
We're not effect currently running applications, so Serial Quick Application and run it again. Also hier steht nichts.
Kannst aber anschalten und mal gucken, ob noch alles geht.
Was soll ich denn mal testen? Ich starte mal gleich iTunes.
Quarz-Debug ist dieses Tool, was bei den Developer-Tools mit dabei ist.
Genau, in den Graphic Tools ist es versteckt.
Und dann muss man da in die Prefs oder was?
Ne, da gibt es oben so ein Tools, ah ja, Quarz GL. Und dann kannst du es einfach einschalten.
Aber Quarz Extreme ist irgendwie eingeschaltet. Quarz GL nicht.
Und selbst Quarz Extreme kann man ja anscheinend auch noch ausschalten, wenn man will. Also es ist alles irgendwie noch doppelt und dreifach vorhanden als Frameworks. Also es kann mehrere Arten und Weise, wie es halt Zeug anzeigt.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall das scheint schon ein wichtiges Ding zu sein. Und das zeigt halt, dass sie, ähm, sie wollen einfach von ihrem Quarz mehr holen und sie bieten letztlich dann auch den Programmierern eine Möglichkeit an, wie sie mehr aus dem Quarz rausholen. Und das ist sehr gut für alle. Finde ich irgendwie cool. Und ich finde auch ein neues Quicktime finde ich irgendwie cool. Sie müssen da einfach was bringen.
Das wird ja schon Zeit seit Jahren. Wer weiß, der kommt dann noch mal ein neuer Finder. Nee, das wäre ja schon jeder Feature.
Naja, neuer Finder. Werden wir nicht sehen.
Was ist mit 64-Bit-Support?
Naja, sie haben jetzt irgendwie großsprüch angekündigt, dass das OS dann den Programm auch bis zu 16 Terabyte RAM anbietet. Ich weiß nicht, wo jetzt derzeit die Grenze ist. Bei 64-Bit kann es so kleinlich sein. Aber offensichtlich, ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass der Kern dann auch in 64-Bit kommt.
Was ich festgestellt habe, ist, weil es wird ja zur Zeit das Safari 4.0 Developer Preview 1 oder so an die Besucher der WWDC irgendwie ausgeteilt. Und ich habe es mir mal angeguckt. Und dort gibt es, wenn man sich das Infofenster des Programms irgendwie öffnet, gibt es einen... Ich muss es mal kurz holen hier. Oh Mist, jetzt habe ich es gestartet. Ihr müsst kurz warten, Jungs. Äh, Apfel-i wollte ich nicht.
Apfel-O ist so.
Da gibt es einen Punkt, da kann man ja mal machen Open Using Rosetta. Wenn man das als Universal Binary hat, was das Safari auch ist, auch das alte schon, dass es halt als Power PC gestartet wird und emuliert wird, obwohl man Intel rechnet. Okay, das kenne ich. So, da drüber gibt es aber jetzt einen neuen, der heißt Open in 32-Bit-Mode. Und ich habe mal geguckt bei mir, ich habe kein anderes Programm gefunden, das irgendwie diesen Button anbietet. Und was ist denn das? Open in 32-Bit-Mode.
Das heißt, dass der Safari 4 in 64-Bit kommt?
Und auch erst, wenn ich den aktiviere, den 32-Bit-Mode, nur dann könnte ich auch noch Open in Open Using Rosetta anbieten.
Ja, weil Rosetta nur 32-Bit macht.
Das heißt, wenn ich den nicht einschalte, dann habe ich gedacht, kommt der Safari in 64-Bit hoch, dass wir den mal für 64-Bit gebaut haben. Wenn man dann aber wiederum im Activity-Monitor guckt, kann man da kein Tool sehen, was im 64-Bit-Modus läuft.
Wie? Kein Tool?
Nein, nichts.
Kein Programm?
Genau, kein Safari halt.
Wie zeigt ihr das an?
Na, es gibt die letzte Leiste im Activity-Monitor, ist ja Kind, also hinter Virtual Memory. Also bei mir jedenfalls. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es eingeschaltet habe oder ob das schon per Default ist.
Man kann auch mehr Columns dazuschalten.
Man kann mit Control auf die Columns klicken und da kann man Kind einschalten.
Da steht bei mir nur Intel oder PowerPC?
Genau, und wenn du eine 64-Bit-Applikation startest, dann steht da Intel 64-Bit-Klammer zu. Ich hab zum Beispiel den neuesten Darwin Streaming Server, als ich letztes Mal schon erzählt hab, der als 603 ganz neu rauskam. Der ist nämlich für 64-Bit vorbereitet.
Kiek an, da steht das an.
Auch für Linux, für 64-Bit. Da steht das und da steht jetzt auch bei mir 64-Bit. Und unser Open Tracker, den haben wir natürlich auch gleich auf 64-Bit gebaut und lief auch gleich sofort, weil alles schick ist. Der läuft auch als 64-Bit.
Powering, Internet, File Sharing, to the max.
So, es ist ja die Frage, was dieses Open in 32-Bit-Mode bedeutet, wenn ich es nicht einschalte und das Programm aber trotzdem nicht als 64-Bit-Applikation gestartet wird. Das ist mir noch ein bisschen unklar. Vor allem, wo kommt dieser plötzliche Support der Anzeige her, wenn ich noch gar kein anderes Programm gefunden habe, was das so anzeigen kann? Das ist mir noch ein bisschen unklar. Wahrscheinlich muss ich mir mal diese Info-P-Liste innerhalb des Programms angucken, was da so steht.
Aber es bewegt sich was. Gerade bei dem Safari, der auch Teil sein soll von Schneeleo.
Dann kann man sich den frischen Schnee vorstellen, der auf der Straße liegt und du läufst die ersten drei Meter durch. Da bleibt noch der Dreck von deinen Schuhen im Schnee hängen und danach sind deine Schuhe sauber. Du machst nur noch ganz saubere Fußabdrücke. Das ist total toll.
Ich höre schon das Knarzen von frisch gefallenen Schnee untertatzen.
Eigentlich müsste es ja im Winter rauskommen, oder?
Ja, das wird noch dauern.
In about a year heißt es, mal gucken.
Wo lebt dieser Schneeleopard eigentlich?
In höheren Regionen, nehme ich mal an, oder? Vielleicht gibt es auch keinen Schneeleopard.
Doch, doch, das gibt es. Das ist ein richtiges Tier. Es gibt sogar eine Wikipedia-Seite dafür. Und da steht auch schon oben, als erstes, For the Apple Macintosh Operating System, Mac OS X 10.6. So schnell geht das. Die Müllheit ist echt hardcore. So richtig weiß ist der ja gar nicht. Der ist nur so ein bisschen heller. Aber man stellt sich das natürlich dann auch gleich irgendwie so vor. Und jetzt schalte ich doch mal hier auf Deutsch um, damit ich nicht irgendwie alles in imperial Maaßen entgegennehmen muss, Verbreitungsgebiet.
Aber die neueste Neuerung von diesem Safari...
Hochgebirge Zentral Asiens, Himalaya, Hindukus, Pamia, Kunlun, Tian Shan, Altai und so weiter.
Und ist noch nicht ausgestorben?
Laut Wikipedia nicht, aber es ist im Wesentlichen so Tibet und Hochregionen.
Ja, da wird wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile seine Ruhe haben. Da hat ja keiner hin, außer Mount Everest-Besteiger.
Und irgendwelche Macintosh-Fans, die irgendwie den Scalp haben wollen und das an die Wand zeigen. So sind wir ja nicht drauf.
Okay, also nochmal zurück zu dem Safari 4.0. Das eine große Feature, was auch schon im Nightly Webkit vor einer Woche vorgestellt wurde, ist der sogenannte Skirrifish. Das ist die JavaScript-Engine. Und da haben sie wohl die alte rausgeschmissen und komplett durch eine neue ersetzt, die halt die modernsten, wie sagt man, Compiler-Features für Interpretersprachen hat?
Ja, sie benutzen Bytecode. Also die alte Methode ist halt, man passt halt den Source, klar, wissen sie ja eh, baut sich ein Parsing-Tree und beim Interpretieren wird immer durch diesen Parsing-Tree durchmarschiert. Und das hat natürlich extrem viel Overhead, weil sie die ganze Zeit durch alle klammern.
Und sie mussten erst mal den kompletten Baum vorher erstellen. Und zwar den kompletten auch für Code, der gar nicht ausgeführt wurde.
Das heißt, man hat immer dieses, und dann geht's los.
Genau.
Und jetzt können sie im Prinzip sofort loslegen. Das ist so ein On-the-Fly, Pay as you go. Irgendwie Buzzword Compliant, Bytecode-Compiler, wo sie noch ein paar andere Tricks haben, aber dadurch, dass sie nicht mehr durch den ganzen Syntax-Craft durchgehen müssen, erzielen sie höhere Geschwindigkeiten. Also ich hab diese Zeitvergleiche gesehen, zum Prinzip noch mal doppelt so schnell, wie das jetzt jüngst schon durchoptimierte Teil. Interessante Vorgehensweise übrigens, haben sie ja in ihrem Blog beschrieben, auf Surf in Safari, dass sie erst ihren bestehenden Interpreter wirklich bis aufs Letzte ausgereizt haben, um dann zu sagen, jetzt müssen wir aber schneller sein als das Teil. Und das haben sie wohl auch geschafft. Und damit haben sie wohl gute Chancen, mit Abstand die schnellste JavaScript-Implementierung zu machen, was ja nicht ganz unwichtig ist.
Da hat auch jemand verglichen mit dem neuesten Scheiß, der bei Firefox dabei ist. Da gibt es wohl eine JavaScript-Engine von Adobe, die heißt Tamarin oder sowas. Und die wäre schon auch ziemlich flott, aber dieser Squirrefish ist wohl schneller. Die werden sich wohl demnächst Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen liefern, weil die werden natürlich beide weiter optimiert. Und die meinten auch, dass der Squirrefish gerade mal der Anfang ist, der zwar schon schön schnell ist, aber eigentlich erst die Grundlage ist für reichlich weitere Beschleunigungen. Und da geht noch eine Menge. Also JavaScript wird demnächst fliegen.
Ich frag mich, ob da nicht auch LLVM dahintersteckt.
Das denke ich auch jedes Mal.
Das ist doch eigentlich genau das Ding, oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen schon.
Aber davon haben sie nichts gesagt. Und es gibt keinen Grund, warum sie das nicht sagen sollten.
Aber im neuesten Xcode 3.1 Beta, also auch dieses STK7 fürs iPhone, wird es ja noch als iPhone-Version gepriesen, aber es ist dann natürlich auch insgesamt für den Mac ein neues Xcode, ist Support dabei, wo man auf einen LLVM GCC umschalten kann. Also man kann auch schon seine Mac-Programme, wenn man jetzt möchte, mit LLVM kompilieren.
Aber schon noch mit dem GCC, also der GCC mit dem LLVM Backend.
Da gibt es ja einen neuen Compiler, wo die am Schreiben sind. Da ist Apple auch groß mit dabei. Der heißt C-Lang. Und der ist wohl aber noch nicht so weit. Dann übernehmen die auch noch das eigentliche Compiler. Bisher ist der GCC noch mit dabei. Und ein Vorteil von LLVM, jedenfalls den, den ich verstanden habe, ist, dass wenn man ja so einzelne Programm-Files kompiliert, entstehen ja erstmal einzelne Objekte da draus, die dann durch den Linker zusammengelinkt werden. Und zwischen diesen einzelnen Objekten kann halt nicht optimiert werden, weil der Linker packt die halt nur noch zusammen, aber der kann nicht mehr den Code zusammenfügen. Und der LL vor allem, der schmeißt alles in ein großes File. Der hat auch so eine Art Bytecode, wenn man will. Und der kann auch nachträglich dann noch optimieren, was der GCC vorher nicht konnte. Und dadurch auch viel besser optimieren, weil der sieht halt das Big Picture des gesamten Programms und kann da viel besser arbeiten. Und sozusagen, das ist wie auch mit diesem Squirrelfish, das ist erst der Anfang der Beschleunigung, also die ganzen anderen Geschichten, die kommen erst alle noch, die ganzen besseren Algorithmen, um da irgendwie noch Speed rauszuholen und so.
Da ist noch eine Menge drin.
Da ist noch eine Menge drin. Ich hoffe, deswegen halten wir ja auch noch den Ball flach, weil es kommt erst alles noch.
Da habe ich übrigens auch gerade ein ähnliches Thema wird angerissen im nächsten Chaos Radio Express, was ich schon aufgenommen habe, aber weil die Aufnahme ein bisschen audioverkackt war, habe ich das noch nicht gepostet bekommen, mache ich ja aber demnächst. Da gibt es auch noch ein bisschen interessantes Futter zu dem Thema. Aber darum soll es ja hier nicht gehen. Wir sind nach wie vor beim SchneeLeo. Und SchneeLeo hat, zumindest in der Mac OS X Server Version, ZFS, Ritvralt.
Habe ich auch gelesen.
Und sie preisen es als Feature.
Und es gibt auch schon wieder eine neue ZFS Version bei zfsmacosforge.com, die 117. Wieder so ein paar Sachen gefixt und irgendwie fein ein Stück schneller und so weiter und so fort.
Spricht da was dagegen, dass man sich das einfach mal so installiert?
Das kann man machen und kann man auch benutzen. Muss man sich halt mit den Command Line Tools ein bisschen auseinandersetzen. Das ist aber ganz easy. Ich glaube, das wird auf der Seite auch beschrieben. Und mein Tipp für alle, weil da Crash da nämlich immer noch ist, man darf, wenn man das Volume auf dem Finder sieht und das abmeldet, dann denkt man, das ist ja alles prima. Dann sieht auch die Platte aus und so. Das ist alles schick. Und wenn man beim nächsten Mal bootet, hat man aber einen Colonel Panic. Und das liegt da dran, weil wenn man das abmeldet auf dem Finder, dann ist es halt noch nicht wirklich weg, sondern man muss halt noch das Kommando Zpool Export und dann den Poolname irgendwie heranschreiben, dass das auch wirklich abgemeldet ist vom Rechner.
Mit Export?
Ja, mit Export machen wir das. Export heißt, du könntest diesen Pool, den du hast auf deiner Platte oder auf deinen mehreren Platten, wie auch immer dein Setup aussieht, könntest du dann auf einem anderen Rechner anmelden, also exportieren sozusagen. Und beim nächsten Mal, wenn dein Rechner hochkommt, ich weiß nicht, ob man es jetzt wieder importen muss oder ob das automatisch erkennt. Jedenfalls, wenn man es nicht exportet, dann crash der Rechner, wenn er diese Platte findet. Das ist noch ein bisschen unklar. Deswegen muss man es von Hand erstmal abmelden.
Ist jetzt irgendetwas tolles Neues dabei?
Naja, der nutzt jetzt halt ChangeFlex-Support, hat er halt jetzt.
CH-Flex.
Und, heißt das noch? Und iTunes kann jetzt auch irgendwie Dateien draufspeisen, das ging früher nicht. Da braucht man iTunes ab Version 7.6. Also man sieht auch, dass ja auch ihre User-Land-Tools da so ein bisschen dran anpassen müssen. Und noch so 2, 3 andere Geschichten. Also es war nicht allzu viel, aber es wird halt immer besser.
Auf jeden Fall noch experimental, aber es bestätigt doch so ein bisschen unsere Vermutung, ZFS ist eine große Sache für Apple.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Also ich meine, wenn sie das jetzt schon in die Feature-Liste reinbauen...
Es ist das erste Mal, dass sie es offiziell auf einer Webseite drauf haben.
Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich, genau, das wird wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal, bei der OS X Client wird das Read-freie ZFS-Support auch mit drin sein, aber sie werden kein großes Brimborium drum machen, sondern sie werden aber schon bei OS X Server. Ich meine, wenn sie das jetzt wirklich als Server-Filesystem pushen, dann haben sie einen GUI dafür, dann kannst du das ganze Management machen und so wie ich Apple kenne, wenn sie das, was man jetzt nur über Kommando-Zahle hat, dann in irgendeiner Form als GUI diskutiert.
Das ist ja auch nicht so schwer.
Aber halt so Pool-Management, das wäre schon ganz cool, weil man hat es ja nicht immer so drauf. Aber das wäre natürlich ein super Grund, mal seinen eigenen Laptop irgendwie auch mit OS X Server zu fahren. Warum? Das ist auch nur Mac OS X.
Ja, es wird zu viel geraffelt.
Ist ein bisschen anders getunt, wie so geraffelt.
Directory Services, da kriege ich immer die Krise.
Directory Services hast du jetzt auch auf deinem Computer.
Ich sehe nix.
Du siehst nix, aber es ist genauso da.
Aber bei OS X siehst du und dann komme ich durcheinander, das ist alles von mir wilder.
Ich finde das meistens schlecht. Wer eigentlich so richtig Bock auf Unix hat, müsste sich eigentlich einen OS X Server machen, weil da ist einfach mal sehr viel mehr noch exposed. Aber ich finde halt den Preis noch zu hoch. Also ich fände es mal cool, wenn sie mal so einen OS X Server für Single-User irgendwie anbieten.
Für Power-User.
Ja, für Power-User. Wo einfach so die Tools mit dabei sind und so. Mein Gott, da zahle ich dann auch noch 200 Euro für 250. Einfach so der halbe Preis von dem Server wäre mal ganz cool.
Ja, Apple hat immer nur ganz oder gar nicht mit dem iPhone so. Entweder voll eingestiegen oder nicht.
Was den Markt betrifft, haben sie damit wahrscheinlich auch recht. Aber immerhin, ZFS kommt.
Und was das Snowlapper noch hat, ist halt auch wieder Exchange Support.
Genau, das heißt, die ganzen Programme können das dann mailen.
Und zwar auch durch Adressbuch, Mail, IK.
Kann man seinen Entourage auch wegschmeißen.
Volle Breite jetzt. Microsoft ist am Ende.
Ja, ich hab's ja schon immer gesagt. Ja, sie haben auf jeden Fall eine harte Zeit. Also im Prinzip gibt es dann für Office keine besonderen Gründe mehr. Also alle File-Formate können gelesen werden und mit Exchange kannst du auch noch irgendwie kooperieren. Das halt auch mit dem Adressbuch. Also es ist schon alles dabei. Muss da nur noch funktionieren natürlich. Aber dadurch, dass sie das lizenzieren, denke ich mal, sind sie da mit Active Stink auf der richtigen Seite.
Ja, so und das Snowlappert wurde ja auch schon an die Developer auf der WWDC verteilt. Wir können jetzt mal kurz bei PTB gucken, was die so da haben. Also Safari 4.0 für Leopard ist schon draußen seit gestern. So lange habe ich es auch. Und von dem Snowlappert ist noch nichts zu sehen. Da wäre es ja interessant, wie buggy das dann ist. Weil bisher ist ja so ein Beta, wenn es so ein Jahr vorher rauskommt, ganz schön buggy. Wenn bei Snowlappert gar nicht so viele Features kommen.
Das ist glaube ich auch echt nur für Developer interessant, die nicht an sich halten.
Ja, weil von so einem Grand Settle unten drunter sieht man ja auch wirklich nichts.
Das könnte wahrscheinlich der entspannteste Betriebssystemrelease sein für Apple seit langem, weil die Leute sich nicht so gierig drauf stürzen. Ich bin ja total gierig drauf.
Ich will sehen, wie es flutscht.
Du hast halt nichts Offensichtliches. Ich meine jetzt nur wegen Exchange-Support.
Nee, deswegen nicht. Aber wenn plötzlich irgendwie deine HD-Movies flutschen, wie nichts, deine CPU langweilt sich. Oder vielleicht ist die CPU auch voll am Anschlag, aber alles flutscht noch.
Ich frage mich, was sie dafür berappen wollen.
Ich denke mal so einen halben Preis, oder?
Wenn sie cool sind, sagen sie einfach It's for free.
Das wäre mal richtig cool, wenn es wirklich die Grundlagen ist für die nächsten 1000 Features und da müssen die Leute dann ja auch wieder berappen.
Ja, weil ich meine, keine Features, also jetzt in Marketing sprech, heißt so viel wie, es gibt nichts, was wir euch eigentlich wirklich verkaufen wollen, aber wir haben jetzt das Ganze nochmal ins Schnelle, ans Leaker.
Das 10.04 kam wann raus? Das war doch März 2005? 10.05 kam Oktober 2007, also schon so zweieinhalb Jahre, richtig?
Das war ein relativ langes Jahr.
Weil das jetzt sind ja von jetzt Oktober 2007 bis Juni 2009 sind mehr so 20 Monate oder so was.
April 2005 ist 10.04 rausgekommen.
Ja, es sind zweieinhalb Jahre. Jetzt wollen sie wieder nur anderthalb Jahre machen. Wahrscheinlich ist es aber auch nicht so wenig.
Das geht schon. Das ist so der Release-Zyklus, den sie zuletzt auch hatten. Seit 10.0 war es immer ein anderthalb Jahr. Ja, und jetzt haben sie für Leopard mal eine Ausnahme gemacht, weil da war ja auch irgendwie Heavy-Einscheiße drin. Da hatten sie auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu tun. Und das macht schon Sinn.
Vielleicht haben sie auch gemerkt, dass so riesen Cycles irgendwie gar nicht so gut sind. Das macht vielleicht developermäßig mal erst Sinn, weil die schön lange coden können. Aber am Ende haben die Leute zu lange das alte OS. Und irgendwie übernimmst du dich auch mit deinen Features, hast zu viele Baustellen aufgerissen mit deinem neuen OS. Weißt du, was da eigentlich passiert ist? Die Leute mussten ewig mit dem alten Scheiß arbeiten und der neue war so viel nicht fertig und so weiter, was sie nicht hinbekommen haben. WinFS haben sie gleich ganz geskippt, haben sie gar nicht hingekriegt. Vielleicht sind kürzere Cycles ja am Ende noch besser. Also ich würde es grad sogar so sehen.
Naja, wenn man das mit Windows vergleicht, sind 2,5 Jahre immer noch ein kurzer Cycle.
Aber Apple hat es ja auch ein bisschen einfacher. Die müssen sich halt nicht um 12 Millionen Grafikkarten und Treiber kümmern, sondern nur um 10.
Klar. Aber dafür sind sie immer kritisiert worden. Und es wurde ja immer gesagt, ihr habt ja Nachteile, weil ihr habt ja keine offene Plattform. Und die haben immer gesagt, wir wissen es besser. Und jetzt wissen sie es besser. Und jetzt zahlt sich das voll aus.
Das sind ja auch, für bestimmte Leute ist es ja auch immer noch ein Nachteil, dass du halt nicht alles mögliche Zeug einbauen kannst. Aber es hat halt auch Vorteile. Und für mich überwiegen die.
Tja, ich frag mich ja, ob noch was anderes kommt, was wir jetzt irgendwie gesehen haben, nämlich so eine Art Upstore. Ob Apple wirklich da nochmal in das Business reingeht. Und zwar weniger, um jetzt den Vertrieb zu machen.
Du meinst das Snowlappert nur noch, deswegen heißt das Snowlappert, da kommt nur noch die weiße Ware rein?
Kurzzeitig. Fairplay, Tralala, Programme direkt für deinen Computer mit Seriennummer zusammengekryptet irgendwie. Na ja, du hättest den gleichen Vorteil wie auf dem iPhone. Du hättest halt irgendwie Virenfreiheit und was nicht alles, aber ich kann mir auch nicht wirklich vorstellen, dass das kommt. Weil das ja irgendwie, letztendlich bedeutet das dann, wenn es konsequent ist, alles müsste irgendwie so sein. Dafür haben die Leute viel zu viele alte Programme, die sie noch rumgegangen haben. Also ich glaube, das lässt sie nicht machen, aber vielleicht...
Vielleicht machen sie es ja nur für 64 Bitcodes.
Vielleicht können sie auch diese Input-Manager dann endlich mal wegschmeißen. Vielleicht ist das sogar fast...
Eigentlich sind die ja schon weg.
Na, so richtig weg sind die nicht. Ich musste jetzt vor ein paar Tagen mal wieder ein paar Tools bei mir deinstallieren, die sich alle über Input-Manager reingehangen haben. Also der Bösewicht war Checks für iChat, was ich eigentlich für eine sehr sinnvolle Erweiterung halte. Weil jetzt kann ich irgendwie meinen iChat nicht mehr so gut benutzen. Aber das hat halt einfach alles gekillt. Es hat meine Klicks gefressen und ich konnte meinen Rechner nicht mehr benutzen. Und überhaupt habe ich mal alles weggeschält. Mal geguckt, was sich da alles noch so festgesetzt hat. Auch so Tools wie One Password benutzt das. Also sehr viele populäre Erweiterungen benutzen das. Deswegen konnten sie das auch nicht komplett killen. Aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Sie haben ja eigentlich gesagt, dass sie es loswerden wollen, weil es halt ein potenzielles Security-Risk ist. Bloß dann müssen sie ja auch eine Alternative bieten. Sprich, irgendeine Plug-In-Architektur für die Programme wie iTrade oder Mail, die halt auch wohl dokumentiert ist. Und auch Safari hat ja auch keine Plug-In-Architektur.
Das ist ein bisschen traurig, weil auch wegen Antispam und Werbezeugs-Adblocker ist das so ein bisschen traurig.
Das ist wirklich traurig. Ja genau, hier mein Werbeblocker für Safari, der ist auch ein Input-Manager. Und man kann halt einfach, wenn man so spiegel.de ohne Werbeblocker kriegt man einen Schock.
Oder mich auch fürs iPhone würde es total Sinn machen.
spiegel.de könnte mir eigentlich mal Geld überweisen für benutzte CPU-Cycles zum Anzeigen von Werbung. Oder, das ist doch Cloud Computing, was sie machen. Tja, aber ich finanziere, ich zahl den Strom. Ich zahl den Strom, um ihre scheiß Applets auszuführen und dafür könnte man ihnen eigentlich mal ne Rechnung schreiben. Rand, naja. Mehr fällt uns aber nicht ein, oder?
So, WWDC?
Ja. Weißt du, was wir mal machen können? Wir haben ja so viele coole Kommentare im Blog bekommen, die gehen wir jetzt einfach mal durch und schauen mal, ob wir alles erzählt haben, was wir eigentlich erzählen wollten. So ne Art vorgezogenes User-Feedback.
Wie war unsere Adresse?
mobilemax.de So, ja, wir sollen nochmal was über OpenCL erzählen und das CUDA-Vergleichen und der LIP von ATI. Ja, es gibt wohl eine. Ich denke, GPG, PU-Berechnungen werden uns noch einiges an neu errechnen, intensiver Software beschleunigen. Ja, genau. Haben wir darüber geredet? Im Bezug setzen, also dafür kenne ich CUDA jetzt einfach zu wenig und auch die LIP von ATI ist mir bisher gänzlich unbekannt.
Das OP-Cell soll doch Open Computing Library heißen, oder?
Open Compute Library.
Weil am Anfang haben sie auch erst mal alle natürlich gar nicht gewusst, was es heißt und so, wenn man googelt, findet man es auch nicht ganz so.
Gibt's auch nicht, ich glaube noch kein Wikipedia-Eintrag und so. Ne, das ist einfach ihr Name dafür. Ich schätze mal, den werden sie irgendwie durchsetzen und das ist halt so im Sinne von so wie OpenAL und OpenGL. So, halt einfach so eine Library, die einen bestimmten Kram abdeckt, in dem Fall halt parallele Berechnungen. Und naja, ich kann es nicht in Vergleich setzen mit Cuda. Ich würde mich einfach nicht wundern, wenn sie sich das sehr eng angeschaut haben und im Prinzip auch mit NVIDIA da reden und mit ATI.
Das ist halt der Vorteil von Apple. Die machen halt den QuickTime, die machen das OS unten runter und die haben genug Markt, um auch gleich noch mit den Grafikkarten-Herstellern zu reden, um irgendwie das Gesamte irgendwie zu managen.
Dann ist ja noch eine Frage, ob man Gmail-Mails auch per Push bekommt, also oder ob man das über Mobile Me umleitet. Wenn man das umleitet, dann bestimmt. Die letztlich ist die Frage, ob Gmail selber Push anbietet, weil das können sie ja machen über dieses iMap-Idle-Dingsbums. Also wenn der iMap-Server iDle unterstützt, dann hat man im Prinzip diesen Push-Kram schon jetzt auch drin.
Na gut, aber dein Mail-Programm auf dem iPhone geht ja dann aus. Dann hast du auch keinen iMap-Idle mehr.
Gehört nicht das Mail-Programm zu denen, die im Background noch irgendwie laufen dürfen. Beim iPhone weiß ich es nicht, aber hier ist ja vom iPhone jetzt nicht die Rede. Hier ist jetzt von Mac OS X die Rede und beim normalen Mail-Up hast du ja diesen iDle-Support. Das liegt sozusagen an Google, da hat Apple irgendwie nichts zu tun. Nächste Frage, mich würde interessieren, ob der A-GPS-Chip auch ohne die Unterstützung der Mobilfunker funktioniert, quasi GPS, wenn keine Hilfsignale und A-GPS, wenn Hilfsignale vorhanden sind. Ja, A-GPS ist, also letztlich das Telefon hat GPS. Und A-GPS kommt halt noch oben drauf. Das war beim Nokia N95 auch später einfach ein Software-Update. Das ist halt einfach nur, dass das Telefon zusätzlich eben auch noch von den Zellen direkt die Information über die aktuelle Satellitenkonstellation holt, damit eben schneller ein Fix gemacht werden kann. Also von daher, das Ding funktioniert auch ohne Zellen. Also ein Telefon, ein iPhone sollte auch noch ohne GSM-Netzwerk in der Lage sein, einem zu sagen, wo man ist. Ob es dann in der Lage ist, an Kartenmaterial ranzukommen, ist eine andere Frage. Also Google Maps gibt es dann auf jeden Fall nicht. Über O Ja, ich meine, wenn kein Netz da ist, meine ich.
Gar nichts?
Ja klar, ich meine, was weiß ich, bis auf mehr.
Bisher von Apple nicht, wenn Tom Tom was mit Karten gibt.
Wenn du jetzt eine Schiffreise machst in die Karibik, du hast einfach mal keinen UMTS, wenn du irgendwie über den Atlantik fährst.
Ja, dann bist du ja im Arsch.
Hast auch keinen WLAN. Was heißt, du bist im Arsch. Wenn du dann aber deinen Tom Tom mit einer Offline-Karte hast, dann kann er zumindest noch sagen, auf welcher Welle du gerade reitest.
Aber dafür gibt es doch die Längen- und Breitenkoordinat und dann kannst du den Captain sagen, jetzt haben wir die Karten raus, und dann kannst du früher wie Galileo wieder.
Ja, die Karten wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall. Es gibt keinen A-GPS-Chip, sondern der Chip, der da drin ist, was auch immer da jetzt, was hast du gesagt? Von PortCom ist es ein GPS-Chip. Okay, der macht halt einfach normal GPS, das heißt, das Ding wird GPS-Antennen haben. Und zusätzlich, wenn halt ein GSM- oder UMTS-Netz ist, dann gibt es noch Unterstützung vom Netz. Das muss natürlich das Netz auch unterstützen. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit das da mit dem Ausbau ist. Das ist sicherlich nochmal ganz wertvoll, bei seinem eigenen Provider nachzufragen.
Das ist ja auch nur ein Zusatz.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Apple mit den Providern, die jetzt das iPhone offiziell verkaufen, da auch reingeschrieben hat, ihr müsst AKPS-Informationen liefern. Wird für die nicht das große Problem sein, glaube ich. Anyway, kein iChat, also hier, Erkat sagt, kein iChat ist eine Enttäuschung. Das stimmt, haben wir schon drüber geredet. Keine Videotelefonie ist ebenfalls nicht so toll. Na ja, also darauf kann ich verzichten. Ich finde es auf dem iPhone, Videotelefonie, ist wahrscheinlich auch, na ja, keine Ahnung. Also dann müssten sie halt auch Encoding machen. Das ist ja das, was derzeit noch nicht drin ist. Sie haben halt Video-Decoding, aber Encoding ist in dem Chip offensichtlich nicht drin.
Ja, per Software ein bisschen hart.
Per Software wäre ein bisschen hart und das ist halt einfach das, was es irgendwie limitiert. Ob der Chip das jetzt so könnte und sie es nur nicht eingeschaltet haben, weiß ich nicht. Spannendste Sache auf OS-Ebene sei die vollständige Exchange-Integration, schreibt er in Mail, Kalender, Adressbruch, ebenso spannende Serverseite. Wird Kalender 2 Server auch wieder Open Source? Ich gehe davon aus. Also ich denke, dass er auch weiterhin Open Source bleiben wird, weil daran haben sie ein großes Interesse. Im Prinzip ist ja auch dieser Card-Server, der Card-Server ist ja ein riesiges Angebot, an die Open Source Community da auch einzusteigen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht, warum sie da nicht drauf eingehen. Ich meine, es gibt so diverse Group-Ware-Aktivitäten im Linux-Bereich, die sich aber eigentlich alle daran versuchen, Exchange-Protogoll zu reingenieren oder was komplett Eigenes zu erfinden. Apple geht halt auf Basis von Web-DRV vorwärts, was total sinnvoll ist. Und eigentlich könnte man sich mal diesen Produkten dazu wenden. Aber irgendwie gibt es Zurückhaltung, was Open Source von Apple betrifft.
Da muss man mal gucken, was jetzt passiert mit den neuen iPhones.
So, la la la, mein iPhone ist nur noch die Hälfte wert, aber macht mir nichts auf. Freut sich auf den nächsten Podcast. Remai sagt, er freut sich über GPS und findet Push für alle Programme ganz toll. Na ja, da haben wir ja schon drüber geredet, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz so sicher.
Und dieser Push Service von Apple, der kommt ja auch jetzt nicht mit der 2.0, sondern der wird erst im September nachgeschoben.
Ja, da haben sie sich nicht was Neues einfallen lassen.
Da haben sie schon erst spät gemerkt, dass die Leute das haben wollen und haben sich noch mal umüberlegt.
Da haben sie sich was zu einfallen lassen. Ich glaube, Palm macht so was Ähnliches. Aber ich weiß nicht.
Aber das ist schon echt mit den milliarden Ports offen, das ist ja interessant. Mal gucken, wie das geht.
Ich bin mir da auch nicht so sicher. So, was ich recht interessant finde, Tobias schreibt, wäre der Unsinn oder Unsinn von MobileMe. Da haben wir uns zugeäußert. Dann hier mobile, ja T-Mobile-Tarife.
Müssen wir gucken, gibt es halt noch nicht.
Genau, wissen wir nicht, ob das vielleicht bei ist, wissen wir nicht. Lohnt es sich, nicht hier bei T-Mobile betreiben zu lassen? Tja, müssen wir erstmal schauen. Also Aktivierung ist derzeit einfach alles noch total unklar. Ja, dann hier BrutusD möchte ganz gern diese Background-Geschichte näher beleuchtet wissen. Dafür gibt es einfach noch zu wenig Informationen. Wie wird wohl die Zugänglichkeit für den Entwickler aussehen? Das ist eine gute Frage. Also ich glaube, man muss auf jeden Fall serverseitig Protokollkram implementieren. Das ist nicht so ohne Weiteres. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, ob es ihnen da gelingt, irgendeinen Standard zu etablieren.
Und dann wirklich jedes iPhone eine Connection zum Apple-Server aufnehmen, dann haben die wirklich ganz schön zu tun. Außer, man hätte jetzt endlich mal IPv6 auf dem Telefon. Dann wär alles gar kein Problem.
Was ist da der Unterschied?
Es sind Milliarden von Adressen. Dann nehmen die sich mal so einen riesen Blog und dann ist alles andere wurscht.
Achso, du meinst, das ist eine reine Adresse? Jedes Telefon braucht ja sowieso eine IP-Adresse, wenn es irgendwie online ist.
Ja, aber die bei Apple brauchen ja für jedes Telefon einen ausgehenden Port und pro Adresse hast ja nur 65.000.
Ja, mit einem Computer werden sie das sowieso nicht machen können.
Ja, mit einer Adresse auch nicht, aber auch die sind ja dann irgendwann beschränkt. Aber das geht schon, stimmt eigentlich mit einem 10, jetzt mal 65.000, das klappt schon.
Sie haben ja genug. IP-Adressen haben sie ja genug.
60 Millionen. So, Snow Leopard auf Max mit PowerPC Prozessoren laufen wird.
Warte mal, hier ist noch Datenschutz und Sicherheit hinterfragt von diesem Dingsbums, naja, wie das immer so ist, wenn so jemand was... Ist einfach alles schwierig zu sagen. Snow Leopard per PC haben wir uns zu geäußert.
Also so wie es aussieht laut Screenshot ist es Intel Only.
Intel Only und es kann auch Sinn machen, weil dann haben sie auch die Möglichkeit, speziell für diesen Multi-Core zu optimieren und das macht einfach mehr Sinn, also auf den Multi-Core von Intel hin zu optimieren und das macht wahrscheinlich mehr Sinn, als jetzt noch für diese eine letzte G5-Generation, die sie in so ein paar Rechnern verbaut haben, das noch zu unterstützen, ist wahrscheinlich wirklich Quatsch. So, wann kommt der App Store für den Mac? Na ja, haben wir eben schon darüber geredet. Dingsbums, wann kommt Xcode für Windows? Ich glaube, das wird nicht passieren. Also Xcode für Windows kann man vergessen. Das wird Apple nicht machen. Das wird auch die iPhone-Developer-Basis nicht vergrößern. Sondern die iPhone-Developer-Basis vergrößert sich, weil einfach Firmen jetzt Programme fürs iPhone schreiben wollen und die kaufen sich dafür einfach einen Mac. Also, man müsste Xcode unter Windows umlaufen zu kriegen. Das wäre ein Pain in the Ass. Das werden sie nicht tun. Das werden sie nicht machen. Das ist Quatsch.
Das Xcode ist auch auf den ganzen GCC basiert und den ganzen Command Line Tools und so. Das müsste man ja erstmal alles rüberportieren auf Windows.
Das ist Quatsch.
Das haben sie eingestellt mit der Yellow Box. Das war das eigentlich.
Wenn Leute anfangen fürs iPhone zu entwickeln, dann sind sie einfach schon gewonnen für die Mac-Plattform. Das ist einfach so. Das ist halt der Hack, den sie jetzt hier auch durchziehen. Kann das neue Google Maps auch ordentliche Navigationen? Bitte links abbiegen, ich bezweifle das. Ich schätze mal, dass sie nicht sehr viel mehr machen, als das, was jetzt auch schon drin ist. Apple hätte die Möglichkeit, einen Navi Google Maps Klein zu schreiben. Aber so wie ich das gesehen habe, bauen sie nur Direction und so, wie sie es jetzt auch schon haben, mit ein. Und benutzen als Live-Tracking, aber sie machen jetzt nicht wirklich so einen mit links abbiegen. Obwohl, diese Informationen kommen ja von Google. Aber die sind irgendwie nicht gut, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie gut die im Vergleich zu Top Tom oder Gami sind.
Eigentlich fehlt nur ein gutes Interface dafür. Also generell habe ich mit dem Routing von Google schon einige Probleme. Hier in Berlin zum Beispiel, ich hab's immer mal wieder, dass bestimmte Straßen nicht gefunden werden. Das ist ich so Wilhelmstraße hier so mitten in der City. Gibt's nicht. Kreiswalder Straße, hier eine Riesenstraße gab's irgendwie auch vor einem Jahr nicht. Das haben sie dann alles irgendwie gefixt. Dann haben sie hier die Autobahn nach Süden raus, die jetzt erst letzten Monat eröffnet wurde, die gab's im Routing schon seit einem halben Jahr. Das heißt, man wurde die ganze Zeit über eine nicht existente Autobahn gefahren. Also Google hat zwar eine Menge drin, aber sie haben beileibe nicht diese Erkennung, dass sie diese Genauigkeit und Verlässlichkeit, wie das so ein TomTom bietet.
Aber dass die bei Apple das nicht selber machen, macht ja schon Sinn, weil für die ist es ja eine gute Sache, wenn TomTom das macht, weil davon kriegen sie ja 30 Prozent.
Von dem Programm, nicht von den Maps. Die Maps können sie ja sozusagen, wenn ihr Programm installiert ist, selber verkaufen. Deswegen meinte ich auch, sie könnten ihr Programm billig anbieten und dann verkaufen sie halt dazu noch Maps. Dann würden sie den Upstore auf eine sehr intelligente Art und Weise komplett umgehen.
Dann verdient Apple bei TomTom sozusagen gar nichts mit.
Das ist ja unbenommen. Ich meine, eBay hat ja auch einen kleinen, den sie kostenlos machen und darüber werden dann Verkäufe gemacht. Davon kriegt ja Apple auch nichts ab. Also von daher ist das nichts anderes, als TomTom dann auch machen würde. Ich glaube, TomTom reibt sich die Hände. Das ist echt eine coole Plattform für sie und Apple verdient keine Miete im Markt damit. Außer, dass die Leute sich da ein iPhones kaufen. Weil ehrlich gesagt, ich habe auch überlegt, ob ich mir ein TomTom kaufe, aber wenn ich jetzt so ein 3G-iPhone habe und die TomTom-Anwendung taugt... Ja, weil ich müsste dieses blöde Navigationssystem sowieso aus meinem Auto immer wieder rausnehmen, weil sonst wird es geklaut und das iPhone nehme ich immer mit.
So sieht es nämlich aus, deswegen ist ja mein TomTom noch so ein bisschen blöd, weil Motorrad ranlassen geht mal gar nicht. Im Auto klappt es ja vielleicht nochmal für eine halbe Stunde oder tagsüber, aber Motorrad kannst du ja so rausziehen, ist weg.
Ja, und jetzt kannst du ja so ein schönes Stativ für dein iPhone vorne bauen und dann hast du eine Navigation und wenn du weißt, wo du langfährst, kannst du noch einen Film gucken, während du fährst.
Genau, und telefonieren.
Videotelefonie.
Okay, haben wir hier noch eine Frage? Oh, da ist aber viel hier, meine Herren.
Ja, mach schnell, die fangen gerade unten an. Ach nee, die hören uns ja gerade noch nicht.
Vielleicht tun sie es trotzdem. Wie lange glaubt ihr, wird Apple noch an seiner T-Mobile-Strategie festhalten? Ist das das einzige, was in ihnen abhält? Ja, uns auch. Also, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, das wird noch eine Weile laufen, weil die T-Mobile-Strategie ist die Strategie, die sie weltweit fahren und auch wenn wir das nicht gut finden, aus ihrer Sicht macht das halt Sinn.
Das macht total Sinn, weil die T-Mobile bisher die einzigen waren, die halt Edge hatten und sie hatten ja nur Edge, da macht das nicht mehr Sinn, jetzt natürlich weniger.
Aber AGPS ist auch noch so eine Sache. Dann muss Voice Mail halt auch zuverlässig angeboten werden.
Das haben wir aber anscheinend auch schnell implementiert.
Ja klar, aber muss halt auch getan werden und muss eben auch die Verpflichtung da sein. Und von daher haben sie schon ein Interesse daran, mit einem Provider einen speziellen Vertrag zu haben. Wovon sie abgerückt sind, sind exklusive Verträge für Märkte. Wir haben jetzt Länder mit mehreren Anbietern. Insofern hat sich schon mal eine ganze Menge geändert. Warum das jetzt in Deutschland so nicht ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke mal, das hat was damit zu tun, dass Deutschland und England sozusagen von Anfang an dabei waren. Gibt es für Frankreich eigentlich noch einen zweiten Anbieter? Oder ist das auch nur Orange? Ich glaube, es ist nur Orange. Von daher würde das diese These bestätigen. Also, man steckt ja nicht drin.
Software kommt erst im 11. Juli, Telefon auch.
Ich gucke nochmal, ob irgendjemand noch Franz irgendwie macht. Aber ich glaube, nee, es ist nur Orange. Ja, so, was haben wir noch? Nochmal Tobias hier. Pushdienst, etliche viel Speicherplatz? Naja, viel Speicherplatz, nicht mehr als vorher, ne? Achso, das bezieht sich auf diese.mec-Geschichte, beziehungsweise MobileMe. Das war eine Antwort, also nicht an uns. Ist denn Push, Email und Chrome nur mit MobileMe möglich? Haben wir schon gesagt, nein, geht auch mit Exchange und geht dann auch mit 10.6, aber kurzfristig wahrscheinlich nur mit MobileMe und mit Exchange-Servern. Ja, hier wird auch nochmal diese Kartengeschichte und TomTom angesprochen. Ich denke, das haben wir irgendwie ausführlich bedient. Ja, Bluetooth für die Apple-Tastatur, das wäre in der Tat cool. Das verstehe ich auch nicht, warum sie es nicht machen.
Nein, ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Also das wäre nun wirklich kein großer Aufwand. Das haben sie alles schon.
Vor allem kannst du dir vorstellen, wie viele Bluetooth-Tastaturen sie plötzlich verkaufen könnten.
Ja, ich habe so einen Teil. Ich habe mir so ein Ding gekauft, das ist super. Diese Apple-Bluetooth-Tastatur ist einfach der Hammer. Schön klein und so. Ich hätte zwar ganz gerne noch mit Trackpad, dass ich mir diese Maus sparen kann, wenn ich nur so ein Device habe. Und dann genauso damit arbeite, wie jetzt hier mit dem Laptop, so mit einer Handlapplagefläche, dann wäre es auch einfacher zu tippen. Das wäre nochmal was für die Zukunft, aber so grundsätzlich ist das eine coole Sache. Aber das wäre in der Tat fürs iPhone geil, dann könnte man einfach da besser tippen. Aber, I don't know, warum sie das nicht als wichtig ansehen, verstehe ich nicht. Ja, UMTS direkt ins MacBook Air einbauen, tja.
Das ist ja was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe. Das muss eigentlich mal rein langsam.
Das finde ich eigentlich auch. Du meinst, dass sie nicht nur GPS einbauen, sondern auch UMTS, dass sie das iPhone einbauen?
Auch mit Spezialkarten, dass es nur so eine Daten-UMTS-Karte gibt demnächst. Nichts telefonieren, sondern die bleiben auch immer da drin, sind fest oder muss gar keine Karte mehr einbauen.
Ein SIM-Kartenslot für das MacBook.
Ne, auch SIM-Karte kann man ja alles weglassen. Ich meine, man muss ja eigentlich gar keine SIM-Karte haben. Man muss halt irgendwie, kann alles in Chip irgendwie sein. Karte ist auch nur so eine Art Registrierungsnummer, dass du die auch mal wechseln kannst. Aber eigentlich könnte man doch alles auf einen Chip packen, der auch immer drin bleibt. Es wird halt nicht mehr gewechselt.
Ach so, du meinst, dass du mit deinem MacBook-Gerät auch gleichzeitig einen Provider-Vertrag kriegst? Ja, aber dann kannst du ja auch gar nichts mehr wechseln. Nö, das fände ich schon gut, dass ich den Provider dann auch... Ich meine, gut, dann kommt wahrscheinlich die gleiche Frage auf, wie mit welchem Provider darf ich den jetzt überhaupt benutzen. Aber wenn es darum geht, Internet auf den Laptop zu bringen, eine SIM-Kartenslot einzubauen und eben auch noch das, was sie ins iPhone einbauen, auch noch mit MacBook Air oder alle MacBooks mit einzubauen, ich bin dafür. Ich meine, wenn sich jetzt beim Telefon, früher war das immer so, es gab viel zu viele unterschiedliche Netze und da habe ich irgendwie völlig verstanden, dass sie das nicht gemacht haben. Genauso wie TV eigentlich nie wirklich ein Standard war bei Max. Es gab da zwar mal so einen ersten Versuch, aber das hat sich ja auch alles nicht als sinnvoll erachtet. Es war einfach, die Länder waren zu unterschiedlich, Regulationen waren zu unterschiedlich und so weiter. Und jetzt allerdings ist die Sache durch. Jetzt ist es einfach UMTS, ist einfach der Standard, alle wollen das haben, man kann damit ordentlich surfen. Warum nicht direkt ins MacBook Air einbauen?
Und die Amis haben es auch.
Genau.
Die hatten ja sonst immer kein Gas Amp, wie irgendetwas anderes.
Also wir sind dafür, wir sind der Meinung. Wir wollen das auch haben.
Wir wollen halt einen Mobile Max haben.
So, genau, wir wollen einen Mobile Max. Schöner Punkt, genau, wir wollen einen Mobile Max. Hier wird jetzt viel über Spellchecking und so weiter gesagt, Sicherheit, Pushdienst und so weiter. Hatten wir schon, ihr seid sehr gespannt, auf den Podcast. Dann hoffe ich mal, dass es auch gefällt hier mit Ohne Max. Denn der Max ist gerade mobile. Aha, den wissen wir schon mal. Der war schon mal schlecht. Ja, was haben wir denn noch sozusagen hinterherzuschmeißen? Ich könnte noch ein paar Erfahrungsberichte bringen. Oh Gott, wir sind schon bei 2 Stunden und 20 Minuten.
Neuer Rekord.
Neuer Rekord. Aber ich dachte mir das schon. WWDC ist halt einfach ein fettes Thema und es gibt endlich mal was zu berichten. Bevor wir angefangen haben mit dem Recording, was ich gemacht habe? Ich habe 907-mal mein Passwort eingegeben.
Wie? 907-mal?
907-mal. Ist kein Witz, ich habe echt 907-mal mein scheiß Passwort eingegeben. Warum? Weil meine Keychain korrupt war. Das war vielleicht kacke. Ich konnte seit einiger Zeit keine neuen Entries mehr aufnehmen. Und ich konnte auch keine löschen. Wenn ich im Keychain-Access, also im Schlüsselbund, einfach einen Eintrag gelöscht habe, weil da gesagt ist, es ist korrupt.
Du musstest für alle Einträge dein Passwort anzeigen lassen und dafür musstest du jedes Mal dein Passwort eingeben.
Das Beruhigende war, genau, das Beruhigende war, nicht anzeigen lassen, sondern früher ging folgendes nicht. Man konnte nicht einen Eintrag von einer Keychain in die andere übertragen. Das geht jetzt mit Dreck und Drop. Ich weiß nicht seit wann, aber es geht. Hat mich gefreut. Ich benutze halb 10, 5, 3. Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt gerade letzte Woche kam. Es geht auf jeden Fall. Aber um diesen Kopiervorgang durchzuführen, innerhalb von Keychain Access, musst du Keychain Access Zugriff erlauben auf diesen Eintrag, weil er ihn ja entschlüsseln muss, um ihn dann in der neuen Keychain mit dem neuen Passwort wieder zu verschlüsseln. Also kommt jedes Mal der Dialog hoch, Keychain Access möchte gerne auf diesen Eintrag zugreifen. Darf der das?
Passwort eingeben.
907 Mal.
Aber das ist doch ein ganz einfacher Trick. Du änderst vorher dein Passwort auf A. Du hast jetzt nicht 907 mal den 40 buchstabenlangen Passwort eingegeben, oder?
Du kannst das, doch, aber ich tippe das genau. Wieso kann ich das Passwort ändern? Bei der Keychain? Kann ich doch gar nicht.
Na doch, das verwaltet doch nur so ein Key, der unten drunter ist und dir erlaubt ist, auf den Key zuzugreifen, oben kannst du doch ändern.
Warte mal.
Nee, ich kann mein Passwort nicht ändern.
Sicher?
Wenn du eine Keychain angelegt hast, dann ist alles da drin mit dem Ding, kannst du nicht ändern.
Wie denn?
Also ich wüsste nicht wie.
Na, System Preferences. Der ändert das für dich im Keychain mit. Was denkst denn du?
Wie System Preferences?
Na hier, Userverwaltung, da gehst du hin und sagst...
Ah nee, hier, Change Passwort vor. Ach, ich Idiot. Nicht so lang. Ich tippe das auch irgendwie.
Wie viele Zeichen? Zehn?
Sag ich jetzt nicht. Er meint auf jeden Fall Password Strength Weak. Wie auch immer, ich war so im Rausch irgendwie. Ich hab hier so... Hab's einfach getippt, weil ich dachte auch am Anfang, es können auch nicht so viele sein, weil wenn du so auf Always Allow machst, dann kommt das halt auch nur einmal. Ich musste ja auch ein paar Mal hin und her testen, weil ich mir nicht so ganz klar war, ob das dann auch zuverlässig funktioniert. Aber danach hatte ich halt alle in eine neue Keychain übertragen, hab die alte dann weggeschoben.
Und diesen Repariermodus von dem Keychain hast du probiert?
Repariermodus? Wie?
Na, der Keychain, da gibt's doch so...
Oh, es gibt eine First Aid. Oh, das ist ja interessant. Oh, dann muss ich jetzt gleich mal die alte nochmal nehmen und gucken, ob ich die repariert bekommen hätte. Bitte. Mann, ich weiß nichts mehr.
Einmal mit Probearbeit.
Ja, früher war ich echt ein... Stimmt. Als ich... Ich hatte auch irgendwie noch das... Irgendwas, so ein Gefühl. Ich dachte, das wäre so eine externe Applikation. Okay, na dann importiere ich da hier mal meine alte mal wieder als FUBAR und repariere das mal.
Wenn es klappt.
Wie geht das? Ach ja, hier in Keychain. Ah, das musst du auch erstmal finden. Hidden Features. So, Verify.
So, haben wir denn sonst noch was?
Verification failed. You should choose the repair option to fix them. Ja, ich hab noch was. Repair failed. Nee, also er kann ihn auch nicht reparieren.
Okay, er hat Glück gehabt. Also Pech gehabt.
Aber egal, ich hab sie mit Dreck und Drop irgendwie alle rauskriegen können. Also finde ich natürlich auch interessant, dass das überhaupt geht. Also dass irgendwie Keychain, ich meine, meine verschlüsselten Daten, deswegen benutze ich auch kein verschlüsseltes Home derzeit, weil irgendwie...
Dafür gibt es ja Backups.
Dafür gibt es Backups. Na gut, da ist natürlich immer noch das...
Wobei, wenn eine Datei korrupt wird, dann wird auch die korrupte Datei irgendwann ins Backup wandern.
Eben, ich traue dem ganzen noch nicht. Ich hätte ganz gern Verschlüsselung auf dem ganzen Fallsystem.
ZFS hoffe ich.
Aber wo wir gerade bei System Updates waren, es gab ja mal ein 10.5.3 Update, wie viele Megabyte waren das bei dir?
420. Erst waren es nur 300. Hab ich irgendwie gemacht und meinte, alles klar, ich brauche 1,5 Gigabyte Platz. Hatte ich nicht, habe ich aufgeräumt, starte das System Update nochmal, dachte, jetzt müsste es ja gehen. Auf einmal sind aus den 200 oder 300 Megabyte 420 geworden und der meinte, ich bräuchte 3,1 Gigabyte Platz. Hatte ich natürlich auch wieder nicht. Dann musste ich nochmal aufräumen. Dann hatte ich ein bisschen getrickst, habe ich mein Filewort von der Command Line in meine andere Partition geschoben. Also ich habe meinen ganzen User weggeschoben, damit ich Platz habe, habe das Update installiert und dann meinen ganzen User wieder zurückgeschoben. Mit Filewort kann man es halt machen.
Tja, aber dafür kann ich Updates machen.
Ich habe auch 10 Gigabyte frei, aber ich habe halt immer noch so ein 2-Partitionen-System. Und irgendwie braucht das OS inzwischen echt ganz schön viel.
Da ist zumindest auch noch was bei Snow Leopard, Schneeleo, was sie da angekündigt haben, dass sie den Footprint reduzieren wollen.
Ist ja auch kein Wunder, ohne PowerPC wird dann alles halb so groß. Halb nicht, aber...
Ah, aber ich meine, das meiste ist doch nicht Code. Das meiste sind doch Bilder, Ressourcen und diese ganze Fubar, Fonts...
Stimmt schon, aber das macht schon ein bisschen was aus. Das meiste ist eigentlich, dass die Default-Installation von Apple alle Sprachen mit drauf hat. Das ist eigentlich das Fetteste. Wenn man sich mal so ein iPhoto für alle Sprachen anguckt, ist das irgendwie knappe 500 Megabyte groß. Wenn du die alle killst und nur noch Deutsch und Englisch übrig lässt, ist es nur noch 120 MP.
Ja, man sollte das System auch so einstellen, dass wenn jetzt irgendein Programm kommt, auch wenn es gesigned ist, und da ist China dabei, dass einfach China gar nicht erst installiert wird. Was ein bisschen gegen Dreck- und Tropinstallation sprechen würde. Tja, mal ehrlich.
Ich brauche nicht alle Sprachen. Aber ich mache immer sowieso, wenn ich einen Rechner neu kriege, ich zeige nochmal von Hand.
Das ist einfach mal sehr unpopulär bei mir. Ich finde das nicht gut. Aber ich glaube, dass sie noch mehr da im Sinn haben. Ich glaube, dass sie sich da irgendeine Technologie einfallen lassen, wie sie das einfach besser komprimiert bekommen. Wie auch immer.
Ich habe noch eine Kleinigkeit, das muss ich noch ein bisschen angeben. Letztens ist mir festgestellt, ich habe Transmission benutzt. Ich habe den auf meinem FreeBSD als Commandline-Version benutzt. Ich habe eine Sache runtergeladen, weil ich wollte mal ein bisschen HDTV ausprobieren, die 25 GB groß war. Ich habe gemerkt, dass mein Rechner fast zu 100% geschäftigt ist, obwohl nur 50 kBit die Sekunde reinkommen. Also total überbelastet. Dann habe ich mir das gleiche Tool auf Mac gebaut, habe mit dem Shark Developer Tool geguckt, was denn nun Sache ist. Also sozusagen das Programm Profiled und habe festgestellt, dass es eine Routine ist, die Bitfield Has heißt. Also wurde mal gecheckt, welche Blöcke schon da sind und welche nicht, von BitTorrent. Und dann bin ich halt auch in den Irk Channel von den Jungs, weil ich kenne den ja so ein bisschen, von Transmission, und habe gesagt, hier so und so, und so müsste man ja mal schneller machen, habe die Routine auch angeguckt und der macht da so Memory Access, wo keiner stattfinden müsste, habe mir noch Expertenwissen von meinem Kumpel Erdgeiss Gold, mit dem ich ja auch schon einen Open Tracker gemacht habe, haben wir so ein bisschen rumoptimiert und haben wir jetzt erstmal den Transmission ein bisschen schneller gemacht.
Und was haben die da falsch gemacht?
Na, die haben halt eine Routine, die halt einmal so großes Bitfeld, wo immer ein Bit ist, ob man einen Piece hat oder nicht, oder auch die Blöcke davon, und da müssen die halt andauernd nachgucken, welche schon existieren und welche nicht, und diese Routine, die einzelne Bit prüft, dafür haben die halt einen Memory Access benutzt, also so eine Tabelle, und ist da total langsam auf Memory zuzugreifen, das macht man halt, indem man halt irgendwie ein Register schiebt, also schieben geht halt schneller als Speicherzugriff, dann haben wir das umgecodet und das war irgendwie 30% schneller. Dann haben wir noch so ein paar andere Sachen vorgenommen und Erdgas hat auch noch riesen Ideen, und da soll wohl noch ein bisschen mehr passieren, müssen wir aber noch gucken.
Aber es gibt ja noch keinen Release dafür, wo das drin ist?
Na, Nightly, also wenn man das als Subversion auscheckt, dann ist das schon da drin. Die anderen Änderungen, die kommen dann erst noch. Also wenn wir das noch viel intelligenter machen, das ist ein Programmierer, der meint, er hat es nicht ganz so schick gemacht, Charles heißt er, und da soll noch ein bisschen was passieren.
25 Gigabyte, da wird das auf einmal akut.
Genau, weil für 25 Gigabyte wird durch 16 Kilobyte geteilt, das sind 1,6 Millionen Bits, die da durchgecheckt werden müssen, und das auch noch in einer Schleife. Und das war eine ganz schön teure Option, und das kann man echt anders machen.
Wo wir noch bei 10.5.3 waren und dem Update, da gab es ja noch so einen Obscure-Fix, und zwar diese Sache mit dem DNS-Lookup. Offensichtlich hat Apple mit 10.5.0, also mit Leopard, den Default-DNS-Lookup so geändert, dass tatsächlich immer erst nach einer IPv6-Adresse geschaut wird.
Nee, das war nicht das Problem.
Nee, Entschuldigung, nach einem SRV-Rekord geschaut wird, anstatt einem A-Rekord. Also wenn man sagt, www.apple.com im Browser eintippt, wird normalerweise nach einem A-Rekord gefragt, oder wenn man klug ist, nach einem A-A-A-Rekord für IPv6.
Vier A's.
Vier A's. A-A-A. Und das haben sie dann geändert und fragen stattdessen nach einem SRV-Rekord.
Genau, die wollten immer wieder ganz modern sein. Hört sich auch eigentlich ganz toll an. Wollten mal wieder vorne dabei sein. Aber es haben wohl nicht alle DNS-Implementationen diesen Service-Rekord und die kriegen dann ein Timeout. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange der bei DNS dauert, aber vielleicht 30 Sekunden oder eine Minute.
Ich meine, die meisten Hostnamen dürften wahrscheinlich nur einen A-Rekord haben, aber ein SRV-Rekord wird selten dafür angelegt. Das ist ja sozusagen eine Frage, was in der Datenbank ist. Aber das Problem war, dass die bestimmte DNS-Server keinen Support dafür haben, einen SRV-Rekord überhaupt zu liefern.
Und deswegen gab es halt ein Timeout. Der Timeout dauert halt lange.
Das heißt, die haben nicht gesagt, habe ich nicht, sondern die haben einfach gesagt...
Die Guten haben gesagt, habe ich nicht, und dann hat er auch auf A-Rekord sofort umgeschaltet.
Und du bist einfach gesagt, ich kann mir nicht helfen, ich lege mich auf den Rücken und strecke alle 4 von mir.
Genau, und dann hast du 30 Sekunden Timeout und du sitzt als User da und weißt nicht, warum plötzlich alles so lange dauert und passiert nichts. Da gab es wohl zu viele Probleme bei zu vielen Leuten, nachdem sie es dann herausgefunden haben, was das Problem ist. Und dann haben sie es jetzt bei 10.5.3 wieder zurückgewechselt. Mussten sie klein beigeben.
Was macht denn der SRV-Rekord so schönes?
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich fragen, ob er denn einen A-Rekord hat.
Nein, ein SRV-Rekord bietet dir die Möglichkeit, noch sehr viel mehr Dinge unterzukriegen. Ich weiß, das wurde auch mal für diesen... Oh Gott, jetzt muss ich noch mal nachdenken. Das war noch diese Anti-Spam-Geschichte.
Jetzt kriegen wir bestimmt wieder auf den Deckel.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall da noch ganz andere Host-Informationen bieten. Während A halt nur die Adresse bietet, kannst du bei SRV noch diverse andere Aspekte dieser Domain liefern. Und darauf wollten sie eigentlich umstellen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine kluge Sache. Auf der positiven Seite kann ich sagen, dass die Probleme, die ich mit Time Capsule hatte, jetzt weg sind. Also vorher ist mir immer das WLAN weggebrochen, so mitten drin.
Ich habe auch gemacht das Update. Ich konnte ehrlich gesagt so gar nichts erkennen, was sich geändert hat, außer natürlich dieser neue Spacesupport, dass du, wenn du in einem Space bist und dein Terminal ist aber gerade in einem anderen und du machst ein neues Terminal auf, dass er nicht in das alte Space springt, sondern das neue Terminal im neuen Space aufmacht. Hört sich jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert an, aber es gibt eine neue Preferences-Einstellung dafür, wo man es ein- und ausschalten kann und dann sieht man ja vielleicht was gemeintes. Ich glaube auch der Typ von Darren Fireball meinte auch schon, es ist halt ein bisschen eine unglückliche Beschreibung, aber kürzer kann man es wohl vielleicht nicht beschreiben. Ich kann ja mal gucken, wo ist denn das Space überhaupt hier?
Also wenn das Programm schon läuft und es hat noch keine Fenster.
Nee doch, es hat schon Fenster. Du hast ein Safari Fenster in Space 1 und bist aber in Space 2 und machst dann ein neues Safari Fenster auf, dann würde er vorher zu Space 1 rüberspringen, weil da ist ja dein Safari, dein Safari Fenster. Man kann es aber abschalten, dass du in dem Space bleibst, sodass man mehr so space-orientiert irgendwie so verschiedene Arbeiten erledigen kann und vielleicht die eine arbeitet, braucht das Safari Fenster, die andere arbeitet, braucht das Safari Fenster, aber in unterschiedlichen Spaces. So wie auch Terminals man unterschiedlich haben will und ich will nicht alle Terminals in einem Space haben, sondern eher, genau.
Die alte Annahme war sozusagen, in einem Space versammelt man ein Programm und alle seine Fenster, hat aber nicht berücksichtigt, dass man einfach manche Programme eigentlich in allen Spaces braucht, weil web-Prosa gutes Beispiel, Terminal gutes Beispiel.
Die Beschreibung hier von Apple ist, wenn switching to an application, switch to a space with open windows for the application. Also hört sich ein bisschen kompliziert an für einen so einen Button, müsst ihr halt mal ausprobieren. Viele hat es vorher genervt und das ist jetzt gefixt. Ansonsten habe ich festgestellt, weil ich bin ja ein WoW-Zocke ab und zu, dass ich hatte das Gefühl, da sind ja auch neue Grafiktreiber dabei und dass es ein bisschen wieder flutschiger ist.
Was ich noch notiert hatte, hast du dieses, Apple hat ja so ein PDF rausgebracht, wie mache ich meinen Leopard sicher?
Ja, es waren irgendwie 200 Seiten, das habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Ich habe nur so ein bisschen reingeschaut, vieles war eigentlich auch so ein bisschen self-explanatory, aber schon mal eine ganz interessante Zusammenfassung, finde ich schon mal ganz gut. Die eigentliche Entdeckung war allerdings, ich habe mich selber reingeschaut, aber jemand hat festgestellt, dass Apple dieses Dokument mit Framemaker gemacht hat.
Und jetzt war es nochmal die Geschichte hinter Framemaker, das gibt es gar nicht mehr, oder wie war es?
Genau, Framemaker gibt es nicht für Mac OS X, Framemaker gab es nur für Mac OS X, und ist von Adobe ja mal gekauft worden, und Adobe hat dann irgendwann Framemaker eingestellt.
Und ist das schon wie lange her?
Das ist jetzt schon so einige Jahre her, dass sie das eingestellt haben.
Also die Spekulation ist, ich sehe, wo der Ball hinrollt, entweder ist es doch noch so ein alter Mac OS X Monkey, der das jetzt gemacht hat, auf Mac OS X, ja, oder es kommt demnächst Framemaker für OS X raus, meinst du?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Framemaker für OS X rauskommt, aber ich glaube, dass Framemaker für OS X dringend mal rauskommen müsste, aber wenn es rauskommt, dann ist es bestimmt vollkommen verhunepiepelt, weil wenn man sich anschaut, was Adobe derzeit so produziert, da läuft einem ja nur noch ein kalter Schaube in den Rücken. Aber das heißt, dass Apple auf jeden Fall nicht Pages benutzt für seine eigene Dokumentation, das ist schonmal das eine, und dass Framemaker da an der Stelle einfach immer noch unersetzbar ist. Und ich als alter Framemaker-Fan und Anwender kann auch nach wie vor unterstreichen, es gibt nichts, was auch nur im Ansatz an Framemaker ankommt. Ein Programm wohlgemerkt, ich rede von einem Feature Set, was ich schon vor 15 Jahren hatte. 15 Jahre, da habe ich mit diesem Tool gearbeitet und ich habe noch heute kein Tool gefunden, was auch nur im Ansatz so da mitkommt. Und vor allem in Performance, ich konnte auf dem Macintosh 2Ci, mit 25 MHz, problemlos 100 Seitendokumente editieren.
Ich mache ab und zu Administrationen für Bekannte und dann sehe ich, da ist ein OS 9 Umgebung noch mit Classic und so, wollen wir es nicht endlich mal abschaffen? Ja, ich brauche meinen Framemaker noch.
So geht es wahrscheinlich bei Apple auch, die haben wahrscheinlich auch noch so ein paar alte Power Macs rumstehen, die nichts anderes machen als Framemaker zu bieten, was natürlich echt interessant ist. Da sieht man mal, was so manche Programme ausmachen.
Das sind alles die Leute, die sich kein Intel-Rechner kaufen können.
Tja, nun ja, mir hat übrigens Time Machine diese Woche wirklich mal das Leben gerettet. Ich habe es erst einmal Time Machine so benutzt, wie es mal gedacht war.
So, wenn dir jetzt was abgekackt und du musstest das retten.
Genau, mir ist eine Datei...
Und richtig so mit diesem Space-Hintergrund und so, weil ich habe ja irgendwie hier Filevolta...
Dauert ewig mit Time Capsule.
Über WLAN.
Über WLAN, weil er dann irgendwie auch erstmal so... Für jedes dieser Fenster, die du siehst, muss er dann auch irgendwie schon mal was laden. Also es ist super sluggish, habe glaube ich drei Minuten gebraucht, bis ich dann endlich mal in diesem User-Interface an die richtige Stelle navigieren konnte. Also von der Seite her...
Ist aber alles egal, wenn man dann eine Seite Datei kriegt. Das ist eine große Belohnung dann.
Genau. Also insofern, ich habe bekommen, was ich brauchte. Ich konnte also wirklich mal ein paar Tage zurückgehen und es war für mich ein großer, großer Vorteil, dass das Ding einfach automatisch permanent immer Tag für Tag macht, weil ich konnte wirklich die erste, die letzte Version finden, die noch nicht...
Tohruf war.
Ja, ich hab dann... Also ich...
Das war nicht deine Keychain.
Nee, es war nicht meine Keychain, sondern es war eine Software, über die ich eigentlich auch noch mal reden wollte. Jetzt haben wir schon so viel geredet, aber ich mach's jetzt einfach mal trotzdem.
Wollen wir die drei Stunden noch knacken?
Wir sind bei 2.36. Ich könnte jetzt noch ein bisschen erzählen. Wir müssen auch bald zum Ende kommen. Aber das kann ich jetzt noch mal erzählen. Ich bin gerade mit einer Software zugange, die heißt Merlin. Das ist ein Projektmanagement-Planungstool für den Mac. Und das gibt's ja schon seit einiger Zeit. Das ist eigentlich eine sehr schöne Software. Es ist wirklich eine der besseren Macintosh-Anwendungen, wo sehr viel so funktioniert, wie man sich das so denkt. Das ist eine schöne Coco-Anwendung. Bedient sich prima und kann auch echt eine Menge.
Von welcher Developer-Bude ist das?
Project Wizards, das sind auch Deutsche. Nee, das ist so ihr Ding. Die machen dieses Merlin und das ist so ihr Produkt. Ist an sich eine schöne Software. Das Problem ist, dass ich dann konkret gerannt bin. In den neuesten Versionen hast du halt auch einen eingebauten Server. Das heißt, du kannst so wie früher aus Filemaker heraus, kannst du eben direkt aus dem Merlin heraus einen Server einschalten und kannst dann mit anderen Merlin-Instanzen dann auch auf dem gleichen Dokument arbeiten. In der neuesten Beta-Version, die gerade da ist, hast du sogar einen Web-Dienst. Das heißt, sie machen das dann über HTTP. Du kannst das dann mit einem Web-Browser machen, aber nicht nur irgendwelche Reports angucken, sondern du kannst auch richtig genauso damit arbeiten. So ähnlich wie Apple seinen Mail ins Web gebracht hat, haben sie es halt auch geschafft, ihre Projektsoftware damit reinzubringen. Habe ich jetzt nicht so viel mit rumgespielt. Ich habe nur ein bisschen mit rumgespielt mit den Settings dafür, mit welchen User man dann irgendwie Zugriff macht und habe halt irgendwie eine Person in meinem Dokument. Du hast ja da so Ressourcenverwaltung mit Personen und Gruppen. Hab ich gesagt, dieser User, der darf jetzt sich auch mal einloggen. Sie dann aber nicht... Also angeblich sollte mich das Programm davor warnen. Ich kann mich bloß nicht daran erinnern, dass es das jemals getan hat. Weil in dem Moment, wo ich dem einen ein Passwort gegeben habe...
Hast du es dem anderen genommen?
Nee, konnte ich sozusagen nicht mehr ohne Login an diese Datei ran. Das heißt, das nächste Mal, als ich die Datei mit dem Programm geöffnet habe, sagte er, ja, jetzt musst du dich aber einloggen. Weil ich habe ja einen User mit einem Passwort, also musst du dich einloggen. Das war aber irgendein Passwort, das ich mal so eben testweise reingehackert habe und zu dem Zeitpunkt schon nicht mehr erinnert habe. Weil das Dokument war halt drei, vier Tage offen. Und dann habe ich das erste Mal das Programm beendet und wieder neu gestartet und auf einmal fragte er mich nach einem Passwort und ich kam nicht mehr ran. Guck in die Dokumentation und da steht dann so, ja, wenn du das irgendwie einschaltest, dann kriegst du keinen Zugriff mehr und dann musst du irgendwie Support anrufen oder Hilfe oder dich umbringen. Na super. Und dann wollte ich halt mit Time Machine also wirklich mal retten, insofern super. Zum Erdlichen muss man noch sagen, ist ein tolles Programm, hat super viele Features, ein paar Sachen verstehe ich leider überhaupt nicht. Und die Dokumentation für dieses Programm ist ein Scherz. Also so ein kompliziertes Programm, also das Programm an sich ist nicht kompliziert, es ist komplex, es ist ein komplexes Problem, was man da auch versucht zu erschlagen. Das gelingt ihnen ganz gut, aber sie erklären einfach in ihrer Dokumentation ganz viele Sachen nicht.
Aber es ist ja immer so mit komplizierter Software, dass die es schwierig haben, das dem User irgendwie rüberzubringen.
Ja, an der Stelle ist es ein echtes Versagen, muss ich sagen. Also da müssen sich die Jungs mal auf die Hinterbeine stellen. Die Doku, die sie da abliefern, ist scheiße. Also das Handbuch, was sie mitliefern, also das Tutorial ist kein Tutorial. Das erklärt so ein bisschen mal so ein Projekt, wie man es machen kann, aber auch da wird relativ wenig erklärt. Und das Handbuch ist nichts anderes als ein luschiger Printout von ihrem Help-System, also von der Online-Hilfe, sprich, ich hab nichts dagegen, dass die vollständige Dokumentation auch online verfügbar ist. Aber das ist halt mies formatiert, du kannst da irgendwie diesen PDF-Dokument auch nicht irgendwie auf die Links klicken und so weiter. Und vor allem die Sprache ist...
Na, die sollten ja auch mal Screencasts machen.
Ja, die sollten Screencasts machen, aber die sollten sich vor allem mal eine ordentliche Dokumentation machen. Ich meine, da ist noch nicht mal erklärt, welche Farben sie irgendwie in ihrem Netzplan verwenden und so weiter. Also die Bedeutung von vielen Dingen. Viele Begriffe, die im User-Interface auftauchen und mir dargeboten werden, wenn ich in diesem PDF suche, finde ich die einfach nicht. Also es ist anstrengend.
Hast du schon eine Mail hingeschrieben?
Nee, ich hab jetzt noch versucht, so ein bisschen eigenes Wissen zu erwerben und überhaupt erstmal zu verstehen, ob ich nicht vielleicht einfach nur doof bin. Aber ich denke, da ist mal ein richtiges Review hier nochmal fällig. Und vor allem muss man festhalten, Merlin, super Programm, scheiße dokumentiert.
Apple bringt da schon lange keine richtige Doku mehr raus, ne?
Für was jetzt?
Für alles.
Naja, wenn du ein Final Cut Pro kaufst, dann hast du ein dickes, fettes PDF, wo einfach eine Menge erklärt ist. Und ich finde die Sprache da sehr viel zugänglicher als die, die ich jetzt nebenan adokumentieren kann.
Auch beim iPhone, du musst immer noch irgendwie noch PDFs nachladen. An sich ist da nicht mehr großartig was dabei.
Ja, aber wenn es die PDFs gibt und da die Sachen auch erklärt sind, dann bin ich ja glücklich und zufrieden. Aber in diesem Fall...
Gab es nicht mal die.
Naja, es gibt ein PDF, aber da steht einfach nicht viel drin. Das ist einfach nicht genug. So, jetzt geht mir aber langsam die Puste aus. Wie geht's dir? Ich denke, wir haben jetzt echt alles ganz gut zusammengefaltet. Glauben wir zumindest. Und insofern wenden wir uns an unsere Hörer und sagen, mir hat es euch gefallen. Kommentare bitte im Blog bei mobilemax.de. Nächstes Mal dann wieder mit Max. Hoffentlich, denke ich, vielleicht. Mal gucken, vielleicht.
Vielleicht bleibt er auch gleich unten, wenn es ihm so gefällt.
Ja, so auf Malle. Ist doch schön.
Ich war ja da noch nie.
Bei Ballermann mit Twitter-Account. Was will man mehr? Aber ich glaube, der muss wieder ran. Der muss wieder Dinge tun, der muss hier reden und der muss vor allem bei Spreeblick ein paar Server treten.
Zicken die Rechner gerade?
Nö, aber du weißt ja, wie das ist mit Server. Die muss immer mal wieder getreten werden oder gestreichelt werden. Das tut er bestimmt schon auch aus der Ferne.
Ja, und ich glaube, wir können auch nächste Woche, wenn die WWDC läuft ja noch, also ist ja gerade mal jetzt Halbzeit bei denen oder 3.5., kommen ja noch zwei Tage.
Dann werden wir auf jeden Fall nochmal nachlegen.
Dann werden die Safari-Seeds, hat sich ja schon verteilt, das Snow Leopard wird sich noch verteilen. Da kann man erstmal noch ein bisschen genauer reingucken. Die Leute sind ja ganz heiß auf dieses Grand Central Zeug. Und dann müssen wir mal schauen. Ich glaube, da geht es noch technisch gut ab in zwei Wochen.
Uns wird auf jeden Fall was einfallen. Aber jetzt sagen wir erstmal Tschüss, oder?